wow
hello everybody happy monday
it's monday monday everybody get down
with monday
looking forward to the tuesday tuesday
it's coming up here on our
is this our this is almost our pen
ultimate last week before break is that
right dan
yeah uh i think it's our last full week
because i think we're only doing up to
wednesday next week
so so let's let's review the schedule
yeah so today this week's a full week
and then next week we've got um
basically monday as usual correct
and then we're just doing a wednesday
after dark is that what it is i think so
and that's that's and after dark is
going to be a extremely special banger
a very special send-off
how's the planning for that going sam oh
she's up she's upstairs yeah
she said good
yep it's going great hey guys i'm so
sorry to interrupt we gotta go to break
we just started
damn we just started no we we got to go
to break
we're taking our breath well if dan says
we got to go to break oh we got to go i
see yeah so we got to go to break
thinking i'll tell you what though guys
i need a break
i feel it
it's been a long year of it's been a
non-stop year you know
i feel it i need the break
three weeks
no complaining
these guys who do late night they take
like three months off
don't they they like disappear like
since thanksgiving past new year's we
should do that
i ca i couldn't do that to the super
troopers i couldn't
you know
it's just a three family family all
right family family
family it's a little early in the
episode but okay family
thank you yeah
thank you
too tired for that [ __ ]
same
yes so today oh well here thank our
sponsors curology mint mobile quip and
meundies thank you so much and by the
way
thank you to our beautiful members to
make everything around here
possible
we love so well you get episodes
pre-recorded episodes a day early
and you also get special bts uploaded
for members only
and you get our discord server which is
uh poppin so there you have it thank you
to our members we love you
yeah
this is also teddy fresh if you love
this head on over to teddyfirst.com to
support your queen thank you anyway
how's everyone doing how was your
weekend
it was good it was good we we freaking
partied
wait i don't see anything in here about
you guys went to the freaking saddle
ranch bro
if you want to see it you have to be a
member because it can be in the behind
the scenes
i wanted to show clips on the show
of a b getting all
i didn't send that i i have a video on
my phone of a bee writing though so you
guys went for sam's birthday right
so so happy birthday sam first and
foremost yes happy birthday sam he's not
here and you guys went to saddle ranch
people outside of la saddle ranch is
like where all these influencers go i
guess to get their photos taken i really
wanted to see uh face blanks there so i
could get a picture with him but he
didn't he didn't show
coward
not that he knew that we were going and
i guess their whole shtick is they have
like a uh electronic bowl you can ride
uh yes
did was abe the only one that tried
maybe he was the only one who did it
everyone said they were doing it and i
was legitimate it's pretty embarrassing
i don't blame them it was too much of a
vulnerable experience once i saw weird
people doing it so much food
yeah and consumed a lot of alcohol oh
and at that point i was like this that's
that's not happening there's got to be
people that yak on that all the time
that ball ain't clean i tell you what
i i made a uh probably the greatest joke
of my life at the dinner hold on before
you tell it can i get a consensus did
jack tell was the joke good i have
absolutely i don't have no clue what
he's no idea what he's talking about wow
apparently didn't hit that go ahead zach
okay so we were talking and we're like
we're like yeah you know james charles
comes here and you know james charles
likes them young
oh
you know what i take it back this was
the best joke you've ever had to go
outside and ask them to explain this to
me i was like i don't want to make zach
feel better i just laughed pretty hyped
let's hear it okay so we go there and
you know they got the mechanical bull so
i'm like you know when james charles
comes here and he gets on the bull does
he ask for the veal
i do remember that actually pretty good
a young calf
i just sent the video of a b
that's pretty funny zach i will give
i'll give it up it got me pretty good
thank you thank you it was better when i
was a little buzzing but i feel yeah
when you're everything you know
how the [ __ ] do i open this because it's
just directly in discord i'm not quite
sure how to put it oh it won't let you
uh
here uh i got you one second
oh that's me that's from mine so what
we'll i'll send you a different link in
a second what's funny to me is i guess
you guys got a little respect over there
because i guess they're used to
receiving famous people
and you guys were famous there you guys
got all kinds of free food and [ __ ] and
we did
yes someone told me that we got a bunch
of appetizers what are you talking about
you didn't know that dessert they they
kept saying i paid the tab and it was it
was didn't seem like there was anything
you paid for all these whole again well
no people uh yeah
i just didn't want sam to pay because
she was already like saying like let's
get separate checks so i can pay for my
stuff and i was like that's not
happening so did you
every single dessert on the menu
somebody did because it was so much fun
well she kept she kept saying it's on
the house well yes sam said maybe that's
why sam told me that because she didn't
see the bill she's like it was amazing
they paid for it they paid for so much
was the waitress being nice like is that
and then like you you said ahead of the
time like i'm taking care of it dan
yeah i just pulled her aside and said
make sure give me the bill i don't want
her to get to have to pay for anything
i mean again everybody venmo i don't
want to make it sound like i i was that
generous
they all they all bamboo me money for
for them it sounds like you guys have
fun i wish i could have been there with
you guys we got to do it again because
um
yeah you you'll pull the hollywood fix
we didn't we didn't have that power
surprisingly we were probably the most
recognized people there though that
night people kept coming up to us
i think we already feel early i feel to
finally
just wait until after that boxing match
bro you're going to be [ __ ] dead
paparazzi oh yeah paparazzi
everywhere people be begging
for your autograph
i'm eating over items today what the
what in the god was that was no sound
bite
that was the uh the video that i'm
uploading right now autoplayed
of uh
the
rod the bull
thank you cam i'm sorry
oh yeah i see you yeah you see you
you're getting
so anyway um yeah we are talking about
the wedding you guys know that the there
was a
and a famous wedding this weekend
a lot of people were tuned in
a lot of people were talking about it
so a little bit later i do have thoughts
on the wedding that i'm gonna share
you know
some people said don't
talk about this wedding
just keep your mouth shut
but
ultimately i have a job to do
and so just stay tuned we're going to
talk about the wedding all right
it's going to come up a little bit later
i mean there's plenty to be said about
it
you know it's called news i mean how can
we not talk about it how could we not
talk about this
it'd be ridiculous just to ignore it i
mean when everyone knows it happened
all right what is this this is a b on
the mechanical block oh yes all right
let's see i just want to say for some
reason he immediately put it full speed
on me
like oh please i saw it i didn't want to
say anything and then we went outside
and then cam's like you know he really
[ __ ] you up on that bull like he
immediately and then like everyone i was
okay i'm glad you guys said it because i
didn't want to complain you think he
just be okay let's watch let's see let's
watch let's see
full speed huh well you did it seems
like you did good from what i saw
all right okay
i don't think i would have done it not
good
i guess it's not working
what the [ __ ] youtube the clout cods are
not on your side today sorry about [ __ ]
the god of clout
we'll hit a little refresh
i just uploaded it yeah
it's working on my hand yeah
uh god's a clown please
here we go yeah ab needs this
all right
no audio
uh
oh i know what i did
i muted the tab because i
was scared
that my stream would play
clever thank you
all right here's a b
the glorious 10 pixel
let's go
that is not this one wait wait wait yeah
yeah you were gonna break my back
immediately but
do this
i mean
look at that that looks pretty intense
but i
have you seen that thing in full speed
man
you should've seen the people before me
they're so so slow he's probably got you
on like medium
well the guy before me asked for him to
take it easy i think he did good you did
pretty good yeah i thought you did
pretty good thank you thank you i think
i would have got my ass bucked off
immediately
the drinks were strong that night man
i tell you i tell you you guys are
endorsing the uh saddle ranch yeah it
was a good time i had a great time great
really mm-hmm we got to go together the
food was good
oh really
it was really good i was not expecting
it's expensive it's expensive but you
portions were huge and you wouldn't
expect it to be expensive because it's
just such a like
i mean it's on sunset like right next to
all the clubs and stuff it's definitely
why don't we go there sometime
when we're about to take a break or
after we take a break we can do a little
uh
company fun time sounds good
that's it or we go to david buster's
damn that's a hard one
why don't we do back to back yeah what
we can do both yeah let's just bounce
back and forth we can do we can take a
school bus
field trip
all right well anyway um let's see guys
remember if you have a story to share
you want to get involved 808 hot meme is
the number to call not me we have uh
operators standing by
they're really eager to take your call
well they're not not eager i mean
they're eager sounds like they're like
yeah what do you want
hurry tell me what you want
okay
yeah i mean
someone said ethan always goes on about
his tiny hands but they seem totally
fine to me yeah that's what i i mean
yeah what's with my [ __ ] it's not
loading
it's going to be a rough show off my
internet was a little flipped earlier i
hope it's not because of that is this an
internet thing i mean our internet's
fine we're streaming but
it's all flipped what the flip
oh
let me try opening a new browser
what does this mean
what does this mean
like actually
i'm i don't know i mean because
our internet works
yes
but
it's so slow let me open that i mean
look it did look how slow it is
maybe
cash baby
but if i clear the cash it kills
everything oh yeah that's that's
disastrous that's debt i mean cash clear
is death
i only thought about height until after
i was married and my tiny hands too yeah
i never thought about that when i was
dating if i did i would have put
prosthetics over it yeah like uncle jack
from it's always something yeah
looks good
did i tell the story about the fan who
stopped me at the airport and told me i
have small hands
it's one of my worst fan interactions by
far
how long ago was this this was a couple
years ago me and ela were flying back
from israel i think by the way that was
a great video shout out to uh
the subreddit or who who made that [ __ ]
chief
putnam
putnam
oh putnam that means face putnam
means facing yiddish putnam up
yeah so i was flying back from israel it
was actually like a really like you know
intent hila's dad was sick with cancer
so
it wasn't like a pleasure trip
and
we were flying back
we were just tired and over everything
and these [ __ ] whole group of goons
who were doing birthright
which again if you don't know what
birthright is basically the rich jew
zionist jews and the uh state of israel
pays
jews from around the world to come visit
israel hoping that they'll like migrate
there i don't know
or meet somebody and get married and
yeah that's what happened to me but
it backfired because we left israel
right
because their old master plan is they
want they need to like
i'll just be honest it's pretty [ __ ]
up they're trying to displace
i wouldn't say this place but they need
to maintain numbers there they want all
the jews over there they need to
maintain
millions of jews okay keemstar it's not
right when you say that
there's no context in whether that's
okay for you to say
just chill bro oh
no
but anyway what ends up happening is a
bunch of college age
college student uh young frat [ __ ] come
you know on my trip it was just drunken
debauchery a lot of frat guys you'd be
surprised just kind of a douchey i'll be
honest
well
it's like five of them recognize me and
eel in the airport as we're waiting for
their terminal
and these [ __ ] they come
they say hi
hi nice to see you thanks blah blah you
know nice pleasantries whatever and then
they come and sit with us
and kind of trap us in this thing asking
us all kinds of questions that's not
that bad you know
uh and then they say all right well
we'll leave you to it and then this
other dude
uh he comes and sits next to me i should
have just told him i think i did
eventually be like yo i need a little
privacy
but he sits next to me just starts
talking bro about like the craziest
things and he goes
he goes man you have really small hands
what an [ __ ] i was like thanks bro
that's probably you don't probably need
to say so much stuff you probably
[Laughter]
probably could say less
that's what you said to him yeah
i don't know it was just i think we were
just in a in a rough mood and it was
like really intense i mean we were there
for an hour and these guys would not
leave us alone yeah
yeah but anyway yeah the small hands
comment it was funny
actually uh
uh there was a fan he wasn't trying to
be i don't think he was trying to be a
douche i think he was just a little
[ __ ] i think he was trying to be a
douche i think he just was a douche
unintentionally yes right there was a
fan uh a couple that we met at the
restaurant the other night um that came
up to us
and they're very nice and we were
chatting a little bit and then he was
like i gotta tell you
i'm from buffalo
oh yeah
and um it's pretty upsetting
to hear what you've been saying uh
lately on the show yeah
so you have any
words for
so what's he said was he genuinely upset
or was he just goofing be honest with me
he was he was just good okay but he was
from buffalo that was real but i want to
say to the great peop the buffalo to the
great
residents of buffalo city new york
we love buffalo there's no city like
buffalo
buffalo is one of the greatest cities in
the world
they make the sauce
i'm not good with the trump thing but
they make the sauce the buffalo it's
amazing folks we love the buffalo sauce
to the all residents of the great i
would say again the only thing i dislike
about buffalo is that keemstar lives
there right you know so
if you can if you can't leave buffalo i
get it
you know and if you're forced to live
there
i'm sorry
stupid [ __ ] is that good
yeah [ __ ] sure we love probably the best
we're gonna do we
we love buffalo folks
the mcdonald's and buffalo it's the best
i'm i've been mcdonald's all around the
country it's the best mcdonald's
like a buffalo burger at the mcdonald's
in buffalo
they have this special buffalo burger
folks let me tell you it's the best
burger
they got a great canal too
they have a canal in buffalo the erie
canal
ooh
spooky you know the song that's not that
do i know the song about the eerie canal
in buffalo yeah who doesn't we had to
sing it
in elementary school for some reason
well let's hear it you still remember it
no not really i mean i remember that
there is a song but i couldn't i
couldn't tell you the lyrics you ever
tried buffalo ethan
have i what have you tried buffalo like
bison burger
uh probably
you know probably
yeah it's asking it's inquiring yep
uh though the terms are often used
interchangeably buffalo and bison are
distinct animals zach
i remember learning the difference yes
well [ __ ] me then because almost all of
i'm pretty sure almost all of the
buffalo were taken out
and they're not in the united states
anymore let me know chad if i'm right i
think the
um
bison are more gnarly than the buffalo
right bison are like scary [ __ ]
freaks
yeah scary freaks they are they're like
freaky demon creatures dude what
they look scary as hell
they're huge and they're just like
they're big [ __ ] creatures with horns
i think they're pretty cool looking tell
you true they're freaky dude very soon
you go to here look at that thing man
joel bison joel bison
they look cool
this one has a do you see that
there's birds on that one that's kind of
dope a good one to the left
yeah it's like a whole family burst
jillian that's kind of sick
these look like final fantasy creatures
it's like a disney cartoon yeah
okay we stan buffalo yo check this [ __ ]
out bison
right check this [ __ ] out
[ __ ] the wounds with korea have fully
healed we love we stand we love
i don't know if i'm doing it right
this is it right i mean no i said i
don't know if i'm doing it right well
done don't do it dan don't embarrass
you're trying i'm trying
i think you do it embarrass us dan if
you don't know how to yeah come on don't
insult them
ever again i'm trying
so a korean variety show with a bunch of
comedians
uh i showed a clip from our one of our
old videos about modern art
this is [ __ ] awesome dude i mean they
get so much wrong but i don't know how
the hell
they found
but i'm famous in korea now i'm famous
in south korea guys
mother of god and all that's holy stop
thank you
yeah so i'm thinking of just you know
taking the show on the road maybe we
should head out to south korea there's
good fandom there
i'm down i want to visit i can change my
persona i'll start wearing makeup and
get like a
um
haircut
okay what no the hair you know they have
like specific hair my mind went
maybe they like that i'm
a fat
greasy patchy beard greasy disgusting
fat jew don't talk about my boss like
that
that's not nice don't talk about my
friend though well i just caught myself
in the preview if you're bullying ethan
stop it
oh god look at that stop it
jesus christ what are we gonna do about
you dude
well good thing i'm already married so
i can't believe i shaved your head like
a month ago and it's already like i need
a haircut that is crazy badly
look at this it was longer than them i
think you should it should grow with all
of that maybe
whatever it is superhuman yeah just let
it let it flow man grow it out we'll
still need a haircut and clean it up
anyway
let's watch this clip from this uh
popular uh south korean variety show
with these famous comedians who are on
it
oh mother god why can't anything work in
this world
click it opens i click it mutes i click
just play the damn thing what the [ __ ]
bro
this is so difficult
so stupid
well there's something wrong with
there's a browser on top of it because
now i'm clicking play
[ __ ] you cookies just track me i don't
give a [ __ ]
that law is the worst thing to happen to
the world the cookies law just track me
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm doing it anyways
it's like you're not helping anyone
regulators by telling you i'm being
tracked i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't want to click that [ __ ] every
time i visit a website
it's
it's outrageous well get go back to
reddit and just play it there well
nothing works on my browser
so no cookies for you
okay close that tab
and just hit play
okay now let's see if i can full screen
it snips off the play button damn
[Music]
i'm trying to pause and comment
i mean it's just [ __ ] bro there i mean
it's the way this it hides the
okay well that's right the tv is cutting
off the the very edge all right let's
see it says it's hard to understand art
she says
i heard a comedian from the uk
okay what do we all look what are we all
the same to you
i mean come on i'm american
i've never even been to the uk
just saying
i wonder if the translation modern art
it's hard to understand art it sure is
actually they're wrong i think it sold
for like 37 billion dollars right like
that right so
unfortunately that that check didn't
clear right
yeah what's funny okay is that we
actually tried to sell it on ebay for
real
but
ebay is not very
i expected a little more thoroughness
from ebay but you can just anyone can
bid any amount
like there's no verification
you know when we were selling the nfts
to bid on the nft you had to actually
put that money in an escrow account
right
yeah well on ebay they haven't figured
out how to do that so people just
started bidding it up to like 70 million
i think
makes me wonder how does anyone do
anything of high value on ebay because
like
you have no idea if it's a real
if the if the person doesn't come
through it doesn't just default to the
next highest bidder or something no it
closed and this guy got it for 70
million bucks
and he didn't bail the check never
cleared son of a [ __ ]
i'm pretty sure a lot of youtubers who
have tried to sell stuff online ebay
ends up closing
their sale like um
colleen ballinger was selling stuff like
her old clothes and ebay thought that it
was like a scam because people were
paying so much for it
and shane
tried to sell his underwear and they
were like what's wrong with him it's
right i don't know
a few things but that did jane dawson
was selling used underwear
yeah he has his i think that video might
still be up why is he doing these things
we don't like that he's edgy
very edgy
link me that [ __ ]
gotta buy that well anyway yeah ebay did
close it down and but the thing is um
a lot of people actually thought i was
rich after that there a lot of people
were like dude
are you why are you even still making
videos you may like you're you should be
retired
and of course the whole thing was a
satirization of modern art like we
didn't actually
i don't think it was an earnest attempt
at art or anything like that but pretty
funny to see them acknowledge that i
wonder how they even found it because
there's very little
i mean that was a long time ago yeah i
mean that's an ancient that's an ancient
vid my dudes yeah
good times though
i mean i do love that video
it seemed like the one guy was
more familiar with you because he
knew you were a comedian well shout outs
to whoever
got them that video and uh yeah there's
plenty more if you guys want to do uh
more spit you want you know
as if i can go okay so uh shane dawson
creep extraordinaire
you look back on all this stuff he's
done is real interesting now you know
what i mean
yeah really sad do you know if he
actually got paid for these or was it
like shut down the underwear it was shut
down right he talks about it in the
video
currently midnight and i'm very you
can't sell used underwear
no that's against policy right
if that makes sense
damn bro i cannot i cannot get over how
he just wears the same shirt that with
like pull marks on it i mean
i get being neurotic is part of his
stick but
that's just [ __ ] degeneracy
am i allowed to say that
i don't know
why not probably say whatever the [ __ ]
you want you don't like that he's
wearing the same shirt he can wear the
same shirt but like dude at least get
like a few of them you can rotate he
might have a few i don't know but why
like dude this is so [ __ ] like this is
what my shirt looked like when i was
eight
because you like
it's like i don't know bro just get your
[ __ ]
together doesn't kind of look like the
shirt that like the kid in class who
would suck on his shirt exactly exactly
that's like the bite marks exactly
you sucking on your shirt there dude or
what at least it's not the pig shirt
let's let's be real the picture no the
pig shirt
the one that he wore for like five years
in a row i
yeah i think it's probably yeah i mean i
agree it's
it's not that cute i guess people
thought it was cute
things aren't so cute now
after he got canceled people look at
[ __ ] he does that's not cute anymore
dude
you know what's real i i can't watch
anything nothing loads
i can't do this you guys
oh
well it's a bit of a problem like i
typed james charles and it's like so
flipping slow um
you know what
i can open a new browser i got a no i
think i know what's going on and i got a
solution for you
oh dan's got a solution guys
feel for time go for time for a few
minutes yes so well what i wanted to
show you guys
is real interesting because we've been
discussing you know does james charles
cancellation stick we've wondered right
and the truth is
kind of did like if you go to his
channel now
i mean he james charles used to be
pulling like 10 million per video right
olivia
like his views were insane yeah yeah so
he's most recent video from three days
ago has 950 000 which you know obviously
that's a lot of views it's a million
views
but for james charles
that's a significant decrease
wouldn't you say i would also say
that's like mid-tier
i mean that's a big creator but like not
a superstar creator like he used to be
like if you go back back back back back
during his yeah i mean here look
how far back are you going desperate
um i mean here keep going this one has
50 million views 20 million eight and a
half eight and a half five seven 15. i
mean that those numbers are nuts here
look at this
20 40 8 22 12 10. i mean those are
monster numbers
so that is a bit of a fall from grace
isn't it
well james if anyone deserves to be
[ __ ]
banished to a uh exile island
oh no
james charles needs to be
where would we be without men it's like
pleasure island from pinocchio
we send all the naughty boys there
now what kind of
nonsense is that
we're exiling young boys to pleasure
island
what about the women those vec those
[ __ ]
with their lipstick
and their high heels they tempting us
where's their island
i say we send the women to the island of
lust the men should be free they're
doing impossible things
it's outrageous
this term toxic masculinity
toxic masculinity what a horrible term
the men
what am i gonna do so men what would we
do without dan fixing our
connectivity issues olivia you couldn't
fix this [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
i'm just a
a woman
you couldn't even you couldn't even
start to comprehend such
high-level
i.t issues
yeah
[Music]
yep
where would we be
i had a really good uh what was it let's
see
where women they're just sacks of flesh
to
insert bodies
i mean what do they do except give
birth it's outrageous
why do you think there's never been a
woman president
a female i should say
i don't even call them women anymore i
call them females
because it's just by they're just baby
factories
[Music]
thank you dan
where would we be dan fixed it
[Applause]
where would we be without james charles
he's getting away with talking to young
boys
but boys need mentors
james charles would make a great
captain uh scout captain
oh my god
[Music]
this is a little spooked mcgoot
[Music]
all right let's look at thank you dan
you fixed you really did fix it
pretty impressive stuff
yeah i mean shane shane's also took i
mean chains are pretty high still but it
also took a pretty significant dip
because like
his most recent one from a month ago has
3.4 million again
that's a lot of views but
when you take into consideration
his previous view you're talking 20 20
18 20 20 25 30. you know those are huge
numbers right there man
the dangerous world of jeffree star
i'm not i'm not super familiar with the
jet all the jeffree star uh
slander but i know people hate his guts
i know a lot about it is he a bad dude
he's pretty
he's done yes really
you should do it why don't we do a
content chord on jeffree star or
something or is it just maybe it's just
old news eh
yeah
it's like who cares i mean he has since
moved to montana and has a
like
some type of farm a yak farm i thought
it's wyoming
maybe it's wyoming to be close to his
lover kanye
oh right
but yeah he has a yak farm forgot about
that
what the [ __ ] you doing with the axe bro
why why does he have yaks like why
what's your problem with beasts of birds
there's nothing wrong with yaks but why
yaks why would jeff
choose a yak
what's wrong with yaks i'd not say do
you not think it's weird that jeffree
star chose of all things to raise on a
farm yax i mean what the [ __ ] i raised
something yaks are fierce ethan only
likes to chew caboose look at these
they're called chocobos chocobos
chocobos
i'm sorry i'm playing five
what is he doing with those yaks
posing what is he
okay so you're saying these are best of
burdens so what burden are they carrying
for him
why does he need it
years of guilt and regret
have you seen his uh myspace music video
you'd have a lot of regret too
i just want to know what is he planning
with all these yaks
i mean someone needs to investigate well
look at all the photos of him post with
them he looks so so good
with the yeah all right let's check out
the yaks
star yaks okay bro
yo
these yaks are smaller than the ones you
should have tiny yeah i guess it's a new
farm they're fresh yaks
get off that yeah right not yet
did you ask permission to ride that yak
young man
did you get consent from that yeah
got a lot of acts i just don't
understand what is happening
why is this happening i love that photo
he's yakking off dude he got the hell
out of the way you know maybe just all
the
all of the are you showing this photo
that i have up
uh
yeah that's a real phone no i want a
close-up
why is this happening i don't know
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is this what happens when you get
canceled you go to wyoming and grow yaks
you grow yaks
god help us
guys
this is this is bizarre it's so funny
holy [ __ ] bro
oh he's in high school i mean whatever i
can't hit on a high school we all looked
[ __ ] up in high school
uh
why is this happening
this is his house okay
yeah it's beautiful
okay what's the house like this cost in
wyoming
i it's probably public probably like two
three million dollars yeah you can get
away
really [ __ ] you should do it you
should do a comparison find a two
million dollar hou we'll find how much
it costs
and then find find in la how much that
house cost and let's show a comparison
that's he spends his time on a 1.1
million ranch with yak 1.1 million
dollars for 70 acres
jesus that's 1.1 million all right now
find a 1.1 million dollar house in like
santa monica
i mean that's that doesn't exist it'd be
like a studio apartment yeah
that was 1.1 million
yeah i mean wyoming is a huge state and
i believe it is the lowest uh population
density wise
maybe just the lowest period i think
like half a million people live in
wyoming it's like empty
i mean you'd think that it would cost
that much just in materials though i
understand the land is like very cheap
but that's a monster house
yeah
i'd love to travel there the sunsets are
really really
breathtaking well i know a yak farm you
can visit um
let's go
if you go to his yak farm and get a
photo with them i'll give you [ __ ] i'll
buy you a rolex how about that i'm down
you go to the yak farm you get a picture
with jeffrey and a yak i'll buy you a
rolex i'll book my ticket for the break
do whatever you want just give me that
photo and i'll buy you a rolex um are
you serious yep if you go to the yak
farm
and you have to get a photo
with jeffrey and a yak
a photo he's willingly taking with you
or not i mean no willing okay
i'll buy you a rolex
all right
i'm in
i'm gonna do it it's not happening bro
i'm gonna go to wyoming
hi sir
what how are you gonna do you're just
gonna cold cold show up his house yeah
i'll list my credentials and just bill
is this a public yak farm is this a
place people
i don't i actually don't know but also
the photo you showed is that everyone's
spamming l.a that's his l.a
oh that's his la house
okay that makes sense
are you serious
that doesn't look like calabasas like
maybe it is yeah it does so yeah like
that the hilltop area kind of a little
bit further up into the
canyons okay well that that does make
more sense i remember this was like a 16
million dollar
house or something i remember it sold
recently or
jesus
yeah you sure you want to go now zack
i'm going to go yak off dude this is
what's waiting for you you ready
i'm down dude anything for the rolly
okay
i'll book my ticket
do whatever you got to do
do we need to add
uh yeah
we're gonna do uh the first batch here
okay
thank you thank you to
curology
it's over on your uh desk actually oh so
they just came uh so here i found it i
can show you guys so you go to curology
i i use this product i actually i love
this product so it's an awesome uh
service
you go to curology.com h3 you take a
questionnaire
about your skin you take some photos of
your skin close-ups to send them and
here's what happens a dermatology
provider formulates
a custom prescription cream for your
specific goals whether you're talking
about acne clogged or skin texture dark
spots fine lines or something else
uh all you got to do is take an online
quiz upload photos and you know if it's
a good fit they ship the formula right
to your door it even has your name on
the bottle
here's mine ethan klein i don't know
what i it's got it's got tetra chin
acid and nice
nice
it's good stuff you don't have to think
about it so the cleanser i love
super light it doesn't feel like it's
stripping my face of oil love this one
so you wash with this
you apply the cream
and then you apply the moisturizer all
of them are super high quality products
and my my skin feels amazing honestly uh
never felt better
and it's nice to have a routine
so
i love it i actually think it's great
you don't have to fretz around with
dermatology you don't have to go
anywhere and dermatologists are super
expensive so this kind of streamlines it
it's awesome
yeah
get started with curology just like i
did with the free 30-day trial at
curology.com h3 just pay five bucks for
shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com slash h3
to start your free 30-day trial you can
cancel any time and prescription is
subject to consultation
so thank you to curology
love them
really do
and mint mobile
love me mobile too man
it's a great service
man when i was poor those mobile bills
hurt
they hurt bad
and i prayed for something like mint
mobile
but it's here now the holiday season the
best deal on wireless can only be found
at mint mobile right now when you switch
to mint mobile and buy any three month
plan you'll get another three months for
free
and as the first company to sell premium
wireless service online only mint mobile
lets you order from home and save a ton
with phone plans starting at just 15
bucks a month that's right
i would have killed for a plan 15 bucks
a month man
man back when me and elo were like
really poor i had like very limited
minutes and [ __ ] i don't know what would
happen but we'd go over it and they
would
[ __ ] you hard bro i don't know if you
guys remember those days
[ __ ] you hard get like hundreds of
dollars
bill
could not afford that
well dan's been using mint mobile i have
and uh
i mean
dan i love it that's great it's the same
[ __ ] it's
just as good as the big boys
thing is they all use the same
like uh
infrastructure infrastructure the same
net 5g network it's literally the same
thing you're just getting it for cheaper
mint mobile offers the best offers here
of the year for a limited time buy any
three month plan and get three months
for free and by going online only in
eliminating the traditional cost of
retail mint mobile passes significant
savings onto you when was the last time
you actually went to like a
store
for like i mean it's it's
not exactly you don't even need that
all plants come with unlimited talk and
text high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network with mint
mobile choose the amount of monthly data
that's right for you and stop paying for
data that you never use use your own
phone with any mobile plan and keep your
same phone number along with all of your
existing contacts switch to mit mobile
and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month so for
a limited time buy any three month
minute mobile plan and get three months
for free by going to mintmobile.com
h3tv that's mint mobile.com
h3tv cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks
a month at mintmobile.com h3tv wow
great sponsors today
love them
people be like oh and the other days
they're not great sponsors
i don't know
don't know what to say about that
today i like them
all right where the [ __ ] were we we were
oh the one person who sent this baby
i was just sending killing some time
something on the side
privately to my friend dan
he just saw it on ray just said
what in the [ __ ]
someone posted that why does that look
so wait the hair has changed right
yeah no there's no two hair lines that's
my hairline yeah and that's my hair
no
yeah that's not that's not
ace family it's not austin's hairline
because it's only got one hairline
there's just some [ __ ] weird i don't
know
something weird going on there
interesting
evie did that everyone saw that he
looked pretty good as austin
maybe i should rock that look
whatever i don't know what that looked
like what austin's body yeah you want
austin's body no the
the chain
the gucci shirt you can barely see his
body
abe mcbroom
yeah the one person who's not really
been affected by the cancellation or has
he i don't know has he's gone down
dubrick
no his views are still up dude
his views are still maybe they've dipped
maybe they dipped a tiny bit because
they did used to get like a gajillion
like yeah if you go back a year ago
20 20 17 35 30. i mean these are
unbelievable for a four-minute video you
know that's [ __ ] crazy yeah he also
took a long break so people probably
watched
those
a lot re-watch him mm-hmm
oh here i saw the [ __ ] he pulled
a keemstar and he went in the pool with
his hat on
hold on let me find the shot
that's awesome
love that
i don't know if he had his shirt on too
we'll see here it is
junior no it's just me but i can order
pizza miraculously
so does dubrick do these things yeah
he's got his hat on oh she's naked okay
i mean i know he's not going to show
anything
oh no she has a top on don't [ __ ] me
youtube she has a top on
it's fully covered
i missed the mark with that one yeah
she's got to talk yeah what's with
dubrick he always does this thing where
like ooh maybe i'm hooking up with this
girl but i'm actually just a weirdly
unsexual person
doesn't know i don't watch his vlogs but
he's always like look at this cute girl
i'm with am i weak hooking up who knows
yeah there's like compilations of her
him denying pretty girls and
i don't know what it's about
i wonder what he's really into
i mean he said he's into being cocked
right
he's into like watching
i'm not gonna kink shame or anything but
maybe i will maybe i should
i mean am i not allowed to kink shame
like even like that i mean
i mean they you know i mean he likes to
get cocked i mean that's pretty funny
it's funny yeah i mean what the [ __ ] you
know
i feel like i should be able to kink
shame david dobrik about people
the guy he he he
like okay whatever stop it i'm already
taking my pants off
at least he took his shirt off that's
more you can say for keemstar
but why wear the hat in the pool bro i
just what the [ __ ]
you know what the [ __ ]
he might have a kippah situation going
on
i think he does
all right um
what is this cueing on at dallas
christmas parade this sounds good
oh jesus we love our q anon fans don't
we still out there
dude this is turned into
a psychotic death
pole mean they're at this point it's
there's no distinction between them and
the guys who all killed themselves to go
hop on haley's comment
right uh heaven's gate heaven's gate
yeah they're heaven's gate i mean
there's gonna be a mass suicide i think
soon you know
probably and they're all gonna jump on
uh
i'll tell you what it's gonna be like
jfk junior is writing hayley's comment
and uh he's the real president of
haley's comet there's a whole advanced
civilization there they're all gonna get
on a private jet and recreate his uh his
crash
oh that's pretty interesting
i mean maybe they'll just ride around
in an open convertible top around dallas
sniping each other
helping somebody dude
add that to the savage dan compilation
right there
but i'm just saying this is getting
really [ __ ] freaked out
it's just not normal [ __ ]
and i don't think we should pretend like
these are just like harm like just like
goods normal citizens who when these are
this is dangerous
mass psychosis
uh
i don't think we've ever seen anything
like this in the history of our country
mass psychosis around the country
this is not a little group of people in
some little town you know minding their
own business in a cabin
this is [ __ ]
mainstream these people are walking
around with
jfk
maga hats on um in the open and they've
been there like for over a month now
right like they're not leaving
yeah this this group of people it was a
much bigger group
that went uh i forget it was some
anniversary that they thought uh was
going to be the day that
you know the kennedys returned from the
dead to uh save america and then it
didn't happen and i think like a big
chunk of them were like all right well
uh
i feel stupid i guess i'm gonna go home
but there's a decent chunk of you know
20 30 of them that are true believers
and they're just hanging out in dallas
waiting
any moment now shout outs to the arts
and crafts people though
those are pretty sick oh the signs yeah
those are dope yeah
and like the 3d ties pretty sick what
are you all doing here those glasses
that's the like
oh here you can read the sign this is
interesting
very soon very soon you'll go to hell
here i'm trying to get a clear frame i
mean this is funny
i want to read the small text damn
oh there we go very soon you'll find out
174
uh you don't know jack red tie 61
[ __ ] literally if you try to
send a message you gotta clean this up a
little bit like i get you all on some
weird numerology [ __ ] but if you're
trying to recruit people you got to
clean that up
very soon you'll find out
174 you don't know jack red tie 61 17
wow 21 oh okay this is some re
like i keep up with the q stuff a decent
amount and i thought i knew
most of the codes but i don't know what
the 174
is very soon you'll find out 61. i guess
i'll find out 17 is the q is the 17th
letter of the alphabet so 17 is a big
one to these people they're constantly
you know freaking out about the number
17 but i don't know what the 174 are is
what's with delays i'm sure everything
has some
symbology are those teeth yeah it looks
like human teeth so that's
dope
now do you remember jack
he's our president
and jfk jr is our vice president i think
they're maybe uh hurt you
right that's true
do you remember jack
so he's our president
and jfk jr is our vice president and
you'll find out soon
so is she like
trying to inform her or she being like
it seemed like kind of like threat [ __ ]
yeah it seemed a little threatening
because again
soon you guys all got to work on your
messaging you know jackie now do you
remember jack
said he's our president
and jfk junior is our vice president and
you'll find out soon
okay lady
people need a hobby or something man
look at there's so many of them and they
look like normal people
you'll find out and you'll find out okay
you sure will
i mean yeah
most of them were just extremely lonely
people with very
sad lives and they found a facebook
group of like-minded weirdos that they
could hang out with and it's the first
time in a long time they felt like
they've had friends you know so
they don't they don't want to go home
you got to go home guys time to go home
stay in dallas
there's other community go pick up
knitting there's knitting
watch my podcast you know we have a
great community here how about that
we need to start your campaign
we need to convert kiwi on people to
watch our podcast oh that's a prime
that's a prime demo you're right let's
talk about that i don't know if like q a
they'd probably be dedicated to the q a
h3 pipeline h3 if we could get them
watching they'd be you know dedicated
fans right sure
passionate fans they corner you at the
airport
tell you how tiny your hands are
that's why it's fine you know
hey thanks thanks for watching
all right what is this a new wheelchair
[ __ ] video let's go
whoa
damn ruthless this guy in the wheelchair
just broke everything
she broke this whole [ __ ]
oh damn
[Music]
and there's tape on the windows
oh [ __ ] bro
relentless he's relentless right now
he's relentless he's going back
that thing's a tank yeah i mean i
couldn't do that i couldn't do that in
my own body
i would need some kind of spine man is
just off his face rockets or some jams
on his headphones
chilling my man's like give me five g's
right now give a [ __ ] probably listen in
a limp biscuit
what kind of star is this yo wow it
looks like a moneygram place
he's running that guy over he couldn't
even stop him it's pretty long been
damn
doesn't give a [ __ ] there's a guy
calling the cops he was attacking him
right there
he doesn't give a [ __ ]
are we going to get more destruction out
of this
scared [ __ ] no now
all right well there you have it i mean
scooters are weapons of mass destruction
continues to be proven as as proven by
that
video oh my god
damn rip ripper
oh
mary may you rest in
mobility heaven yeah
may your speed be always set
to 10
and intensity turned all the way up
may your scooter battery never deplete
always in the highest power setting
she's on a five-lane highway no cars
may every dog woman and man spread
before you to make way for your scooter
and heaven ah man and unfortunately
sir
you never have to say excuse me sir
again yeah can we get some ilas on the
gatsby in the chat let's let's go people
i guess we should update about the
scooter getting her scooter and yeah
what happened so i reached out to some
people and unfortunately this scooter is
no longer with us
i was afraid that would have it's such a
shame they probably just dumped it right
that's exactly what they did
it's just such a shame because it really
is valuable memorabilia yeah it's really
important she left uh behind a uh her
scooter and a uh workout set so
yeah
wow workout set huh those are two really
different things
yeah
it's true
i mean that's like destroying a
rembrandt you know it's like yeah who
wants this definitely right such a shame
man the scooter's probably worth more
than the damn house they bought yeah
yes that is true
[ __ ]
they said they held on to it for a long
time too
[ __ ] hell bro we're like a month late
i can't believe it i can't believe we
[ __ ] up that bed
all right i need to go to the bathroom
remind me
i think we did our ad super late dance
so just to remind me it wasn't that late
but yes i'll remind you okay yeah
i just need to go to the bathroom real
fast and then we'll talk when i come
back we'll talk about the wedding
and we also have a lot of good stuff
honestly jstation was on philly d i want
to talk about the streamy awards he was
not on phillyd he was on dr phil doctor
p
yeah
guys
read between the lines i'm just gonna go
to the bathroom i'll be right back real
quick okay
i guess i'll read some freaking super
duper chats in the meantime
uh let's see polly polly g
i'm in dallas was on the anniversary of
jk's death peace and love that's right
that's right i couldn't remember why
they were there in the first place
uh are you waiting until the lawsuit has
settled down to make a content court
about cav kev he ain't get content
corded [ __ ] him
it ain't worth it
he hasn't earned that
uh thank you for all the goose gaffs and
good times i'm going away
you're going away before i do i want to
send best wishes and good times to all
friends and crew thank you well i'm
sorry you're going away
it's a little vague
and could be taken in sort of an ominous
way i hope you're good chris true
shout out to chris true
uh rantron donated
uh a thousand inr
the indian
money
it's in our
currency indian rupee indian rupee okay
13
u.s hell yeah
david finds pressing the record button
chuckleworthy
uh we're talking about david dubrick ah
finds the pressing record button
chuckleworthy it is what it is ethan
looking fresh cool colors on tf thank
you
rentron
uh
queueing on his elaborate tim and eric
sketch changed my mind you know
really does feel like
things like the surreal humor of tim and
eric has just
become reality at this point isn't it
uh can you react to adam mickenter
on the wendy williams show yeah we saw
that just before we went live uh pretty
funny
um
i don't know if ethan
oh yeah i think he wanted to talk about
it again maybe maybe not i don't know
we'll see we love adam
i love adam i can't speak for everyone i
think everybody does donna says he's a
little cutie pie or what what did she
say he's a little dude is a button he's
accused of button
i've been a fan for six years now and
have watched every single episode since
the podcast was created holy [ __ ] haley
uh figured out give back to show my
gratitude for giving me contents over
all these years love you guys 20 bucks
from haley thank you haley
for being a loyal the loyalist
hoopa trooper
i haven't even watched every episode
something to just check out
last time i checked europe
across from their old new york apartment
clothes they should consider setting up
a new york city pop-up teddy fresh for
us new york city fans do you know what
europtica is in new york
does that sound familiar
yeah what is it called
europe europtica
across from your old apartment in new
york
europe teacup
tikka
t-i-k-a like a indian food
i guess like that yeah it's one word
though
i have no idea
okay there's a lot of restaurants in
indian food places and stuff got you a
million of them
shout out though i guess shout out
well no that means they're gone this is
the message
oh well i guess rip then shout out
whatever whatever it is i'm sorry are
happy for you
they were saying uh you should do a new
york city pop-up for teddy fresh for new
york city fans
we should
i mean you guys already did one there
right we did one with another brand oh
right right it wasn't like our own thing
yeah yeah maybe someday
maybe someday
all right well let's talk anyway thank
you to everyone i don't know i missed
but thank you thank you for all the
donations and all those subbies
appreciate y'all
all right guys let's talk about this
wedding
something in my throat
not wanting not wanting to talk about it
yeah
i don't know why you wouldn't i mean
it's exciting
it's good news
i don't know should we put it at the
back maybe it's too soon to get into the
wedding no i mean listen i mean but
you're sure you want to talk about it
though
why wouldn't he
i mean it is yet is exciting i don't
know either called me i'll panic saying
don't talk about the weather
i don't know what her hang up is with
this wedding i mean it's it's it's a
beautiful thing with these two did
[Music]
i mean it's it's silly to ignore it it
happened it was a huge thing everyone's
talking about it it's big news and you
know
[Music]
we all know it was all over my instagram
feed you can't can't avoid it
i'm so happy for them yeah
me too well not everyone's happy
and people are dissecting every little
inch of this
yeah oh yeah and like there's actually a
lot of controversy that came out of it
really even in like this short time huh
all right i guess i better talk about it
uh forgive me eloh
i'm happy for them yankees the aaron
judge got married
over the weekend
yeah
uh right fielder aaron judge of the new
york yankees got married he's an
all-star player he's been you know he
batted a point two seven six this season
wow which is really good
pretty good
you know he's got 158 career home runs
39 alone and 20 what happened to music
was vibing on that thank you
he got married to a longtime girlfriend
samantha bret braxsike and a secret
ceremony
you know here let's see some photos you
gotta see this venue look where they got
married gorgeous stunning wow
oh my god where is it oh that's hawaii
yeah wow that is never honestly
beautiful i haven't been there either
yankees are paying them well man oh yeah
he's a star player i mean he's one of
the best he's best of the best oh yeah
actually they're high school sweethearts
and they later reunited in college
and this is kind of interesting um he's
six seven and she's five too so whoa do
the math on that whoa
that's like a shaq situation almost
can i see them together side by side
actually
well they're pretty private but i'll see
if i can get a
picture side by side
yeah so you know
i wasn't sure if i should talk about it
but uh in the end
holy [ __ ]
is it weird that i immediately think
about you know they're intimate
like you gotta ask questions about that
she needs a step stool man
there's a super famous photo of do you
know who jeannette mccurdy is she's on
nickelodeon her first like public
boyfriend there's a famous photo because
of their size difference
[Music]
i mean that's gotta be
it's gotta be wild
[ __ ]
right
don't pull it up
holy [ __ ] dude and he's like leaning
over too he's massive
he's like a huge dude
yeah that's pretty wild and she was on
like a nickelodeon show at the time oh
no she's wearing high heels by the way
in this photo too
she got like three inches on oh true
yeah
huh
well i mean just so happy for them
lots of tomatoes in the chat
that's for i don't know either um
i mean i'm not a huge yankees fan or
anything but
you know he just he seems like a good
guy and you just love to see true love
prevail like they have this whole story
of
you know being together in high school
split apart drift apart and then they
come back together and then years later
yeah it is beautiful it's a beautiful
thing if you love something let it go if
it comes back it's how you know right
right
[ __ ] beautiful never forgetty i think
you know shax is pretty that i mean you
can't beat that
i mean
his member is probably the size of her
entire
thigh
yeah i definitely think about it with
shaq the first photo you asked i wasn't
thinking too much about this one i
definitely this one is wild bro i mean
this is wild she must be what they call
a size queen that's i don't know
i mean i don't know why i
you know i feel like i got to clarify
something
it's tradition to throw rice not
tomatoes for a wedding so every i see a
lot of people in the chat that seem a
little confused can we please get rice
why are you guys sending to me rice
option maybe there's clicking tomato
because oh that's like the best food
it's a food item it's like the closest
thing because yeah
i see some people throwing roses that
that's that works yeah i mean that's not
necessarily so anyway our well wishes of
course to aaron judge for getting
married we're just so happy for him and
his new wife
one of the one of the baseball greats so
people are starting to throw some rice
there you go and uh we were just super
happy
to uh
to shut them out by the way should we at
least show adam on the wendy when when
william show without commentary oh well
some yeah
we got brought up when you were in the
bathroom because somebody's super
chatted about it so why not i gotta say
[ __ ] adam mcintyre it felt like a
fever dream when he was watching to the
this guy
has made meme
uh
hall of fame history yeah meme history
just send it to disco i'm going to watch
you without comment i just want to say
this is the second time he's been out of
wendy the first time he was on when
wendy was still hosting and he was in
the virtual audience and he was wearing
teddy fresh oh oh we saw that he didn't
say anything right yeah he was i think
he was on the screen so he came out to
l.a
of course michael rappaport is hosting
no he's not in new york yeah
oh it's in new york yeah okay so this
happened recently then
all right so i'm submitting this without
comment
just to acknowledge that it happened
question what's your name where are you
from what's your question for me hi
michael you will never replace wendy i
don't know what michael rappaport is
even doing
but like dude you're not why are you
hosting wendy no no i was telling them
it's odd for him i like him you know
very strange
i'm ireland okay can we get this like
permanent full screen button not on i
mean what the f do i have to do
dan why is there a permanent full screen
button on it
like
okay hit play
from ireland 19. i need your help
desperately my friend group is falling
apart because my friend moses got
married to
that woman
we know
trisha yeah and they've only been dating
for less than a year and she is
obsessive she's taking him away she made
him get rid of his cats because
yep she made him get rid of the cats
because she was spending too much time
with that and us as well my question is
should we be getting rid of him what
should we be doing how do we confront
this okay well i it sounds like you are
you really from ireland because that's a
that's a suspect ireland actually
there's a lot going on there actually um
all right you know what i would say
listen you got to let him do his thing
uh it sounds like this woman is dom
domineering uh but you can't help save
uh or fix the situation be supportive
and uh wish him nothing but the best
we're the cats where the cat's at that's
the question i got for you where the
cat's at
gone all right well just
yeah so
it's just odd to see michael rap apart
trying to give ernest advice i just it
doesn't jive
considering how he reacts to gary on
howard i mean i don't like that show i
would watch michael rappaport just
roasting everyone in the most obscenely
disgusting way all right but anyway you
know he he did it he went out there and
he [ __ ] did the thing so
god damn
i mean what the hell that's that is
iconic how did he pull that
yeah this is weird um someone said h3
drama made it to the wendy williams show
so that is kind of an interesting smed
over crossover
super meta yeah
[Applause]
wow
wow man
yeah just saying this clip is pretty
iconic it's hard to ignore that one
in fact impossible i would say it's
impossible
so shout out to adam mcintyre
um and anyway that's about that's the
wedding so
we love we love love we love to see love
prevail
someday love will be in love
and we can say we love love's love
[Music]
maybe
maybe he'll meet a girl named peace
yo we love
loves peace no peace love loves love of
peace
and love
love peace peace and love
i'm telling you uh and then back to the
talk shows uh chase you're the official
jstation
cataloger
what the hell is all this [ __ ] do you
guys remember js station he was like
gods
what the frick did we do a content court
on chase yes sir okay so then you guys
should be familiar
what's your take to him being on dr phil
how odd is this
it's very strange and i felt like he
misrepresented himself made himself out
to be the victim
when he's just a psycho
fairly stated
let's watch this
my name's jay but on social media i'm
known as jstation you're not know
there's anything on social media
can i just say he he speaks like a
marvel edit i noticed today
guys we i am known as
i'm known for making prank social media
videos
at one point i had 6.5 million
subscribers on one channel and 800 000
on the other
all of my videos were fake i planned out
they were pranks and often got me a lot
of haters i guess i'll say for people
who don't know he was just making
horrible weird trashy
[Music]
free content for kids you couldn't even
call it pranks
it definitely wasn't pranks because he
even went to the extent of defending
that they were real
like like the black santa who loved
fried chicken and drinking a gay potion
and then like all these negative
stereotypes he's just [ __ ]
yeah they weren't pranks they were just
fake videos he made them for kids who
some of them believed it was real anyway
he got permanently banned
why did he get permanently banned maybe
for pretending that his girlfriend died
and click baiting and saying her last
wish was for you to subscribe to our
channel are we sure that that's why
though youtube would ban for that i
don't think so
well we were trying to figure it out
this morning and it the thing is
the band came a significant amount of
time after that whole controversy i
don't know if it was
[Music]
or maybe it was that the story blew up
and youtube did like a creator
sometimes they do where they're like oh
if you're harming the community we can
punish you maybe well he he wasn't
supposed to have a channel in the first
place because his channel was deleted
years ago yeah well either keemstar
right
and he was he made a new adsense account
which he's not supposed to be able to do
but i think the controversy from this
situation is what
flagged youtube guys guys
for example on one video i drank a
potion to turn gay okay
what do you think i got a lot of people
mad at me for that
jay's in the emergency room they don't
know what's wrong with him another time
i filmed the video of me being in a coma
i wasn't doing you can drive hold on
hold on
hold on i haven't seen it
look at this it's he's got ethernet
cables running
under the sheet that he's holding down
with his hand
what's wrong with him another time i
filmed the video of me being in a coma i
wasn't jay you think you can drive bro
should i let him drive guys
over a year ago i posted a series of
videos about the fake death of my
girlfriend
youtube decided to ban me from posting
videos i had to tell all of my followers
i was taking a break thank you for
rocking with me and understanding this
i'll be back
not sure when youtube terminated my
account basically overnight my source of
income was gone
it's been almost 12 years since being
banned i knew my videos were
controversial yes some people might
think i crossed the line but i really
don't think i went too far
he's not showing all the weird races
homophobic
yeah he's just it did go too far many
times and by the way you don't get
banned from youtube unless you're a real
real
real
really shitty
person who push it way too far well
joining us virtually is jay
jay how you doing hey i'm good dr phil
how you doing all right you've been shut
down for
two years
a little over a year now dr phil so what
have you been doing since
uh i've been doing some stuff with real
estate i got together with some real
estate investors and
started buying rental properties
yeah
i i know we're here
yeah i was so sure he was going to say
crippling for a welder
yeah you can jump all over that
when you put up anything at all they
take it down no matter what it is you
put it up under a different name under
anything they take anything you put up
down right
yeah dr phil um basically youtube said
i'm banned from being in possession of
any youtube channel i can't post
anything even if i make a new account
yeah is there is there any kind of
appeal i mean do you
have you
what the [ __ ] is the point of this why
is dr phil like championing championing
for him do you not know any yeah he has
no idea there should be someone on staff
to at least explain youtube or the
situation
also he's banned from disney world he's
been from twitter uh instagram
and there's and all for different
reasons
that's pretty intense filed an appeal if
you said look i get it i've
crossed the line is there some
probationary way you can come back is
there
is there anything you can do to do dr
phil is one of the
if not the strangest looking dudes that
have ever existed
just straight up the weirdest looking
face and i mean
yes
just get a load of that mug dude it's
just
you know and i and i don't mean that
necessarily as an insult to call him
ugly or something
he's just one of the strangest looking
man
he's somehow both normal looking and str
and strange looking
he's got it all dude
is there anything you can do to
kind of make amends
i've tried to email them several times
it's just youtube is almost impossible
to get a hold of and i really don't know
what to do to get my youtube channel
back or even to be able to
make a new one yeah so this took your
income
to zero right this is such a point
this is such a pointless interview this
is so dumb
what did nowhere i was making over 100k
a month and then zero dollars now 100k a
month and it just went to nothing yeah
wow yeah overnight if you've learned
something what would you pass on to
those that aspire to do you're making
100 grand a month what do you what do
you say to these guys that are following
along the path that you've been down uh
it takes a lot of dedication keep on
doing it every day or as much as
possible but the biggest thing nowadays
is to never
do anything that
anybody could think is controversial at
all i'm definitely never going to do
anything controversial offensive
uh you know
shut up this is dr phil is doing the
least
immediately after being banned off
youtube he goes on instagram and starts
saying that covet is fake yeah that's
why you got me i i just don't understand
why did you bring him on
you didn't challenge him you didn't talk
to him about his controversial past you
didn't even ask why he got like ask
questions about all this and that
what a dumb point in this interview what
is wrong with you dr phil you are such a
pathetic nothing burger
it's time for him to buy a ranch and
some yaks yeah just retire
dr phil or jay
um
is it possible he like paid dr phil
to be on i don't think so
they're just they're just just desperate
for content like everybody i don't think
so
hey
i mean he could have made an interesting
interview about it if he did some
research talk to him i thought he'd
bring him out like bad bad baby and do
like an intervention or something right
golly that was some weird [ __ ]
you know
all right let's talk about the streamies
that was pretty good
um maybe we should do our other two ads
before we get into it yeah
thank you thank you to quip
love me some quip toothbrushes
is the only
so quiet
zach just got back he was in the
restroom
there we go love some clip toothbrushes
it's the only toothbrush i use and let
me tell you why the bristles first of
all are soft ultra soft
man it's hard to find a bristle that's
soft and doesn't damage your gums let me
tell you something about gums they don't
grow back you gotta respect gums
so important
that's first
second of all it's a vibrating
toothbrush all dentists pretty much
agree except for that one out of ten
piece of [ __ ] doesn't know anything nine
ten agree
vibrating brush
that's what it is it's a slick little
tube you don't need a huge charging pack
when you click it to vibrate
it times a perfect two minute brush so
you know you're brushing your teeth what
the dentists recommend every time
30 seconds pulsates 30 seconds 30
seconds 30 seconds in each quadrant boom
then you know when you're done and you
got the perfect brush it's quick
it is what it is and absolutely love it
um you know they've sold over seven
million holy frick
that's pretty impressive it's
lightweight it's sleek for adults and
kids there's no wires or bulky chargers
to weigh you down
it's just a great product around and i
love it
they got floss they've got reusable
floss picks
they've got gum
long lasting sugar-free you know chewing
gum is one of the best things you can do
for your teeth sugar-free gum chew that
after a meal for like 30 minutes makes a
huge difference you know
they got mouthwash
um in addition to brush heads quip also
delivers fresh flush toothpaste
mouthwash gum
every three months for just five bucks
shipping is free and you can save money
and skip the hostel and bustle of
shopping in store during the holidays so
even more good news quip is running the
best deal of the year which means that
you won't be paying through the teeth
when you give better oral health this
year if you want it if you go to get
quipped.com h3tv right now on top of
their holiday savings you'll get your
first refill for free that's your first
refill for free and up to forty percent
off of the bundles at get quipped dot
com slash h3tv that's
g-e-t-q-u-y-p dot com slash h3tv quips
it's the good
habit
company it's actually really affordable
too they usually put the price in here
but i took it out for some reason but
the price is great so
go check it out uh equipped.com h3tv
thank you thank you
and finally it's me undies
who we love so well
somehow it's already the end of 2021 but
that means we're time to roast those
nuts chestnuts that is
i made that joke last summer you know
still good
it's still good roast those chestnuts
uh it's the time of year when we're
spending hours days or even months
trying to find the best gifts for our
favorite people and luckily meundies is
back with their ultimate gift guide so
you can save time and focus on going
home for the holiday with the coziest
gift ever
i love my undies the underwear unmatched
you're an adult
it's time to upgrade
it's time to stop lugging around these
disintegrating underwear your mom bought
you in eighth grade
it's time to grow up and get some adult
underwear that's soft and breathable
it's comfortable and when you drop trout
people are going to be impressed they'll
be like damn boy this man has his [ __ ]
together he's got real underwear
it makes a difference
true
really does
i love it i'm fat i'm thick
i need that soft [ __ ]
you know and if you're a onesie person
or pj person they've got set matched
sets for you and your loved ones
get your festivities on with myandy's
holiday collection featuring classic
plaids you know and love and sweater
inspired prints that will quickly become
favorites their undies loungewear and
sleepwear are made out of soft
breathable stretchy fabric that are
ideal for sitting fireside with loved
ones and chatting about life over a cup
of hot cocoa
get the family photo you've always
dreamed of with matching pj sets or make
every day a spa day with the new plush
robes and plush slippers whatever you
decide everyone will be rolling into the
new year comfier than before sizes are
available in extra small to 4xl mandy's
has a little something for everyone on
your list mandy's has a great offer for
our listeners for any first time
purchase you get 15 off and free
shipping right to your door your days of
fighting for your life in the mall
parking lot are over
to get 15 off your first order free
shipping and 100 satisfaction guarantee
go to meundies.com h3 that's
meundies.com
h3 thank you thank you
[Music]
all right i want to talk about oh do we
have any calls we haven't taken a call
let's see we do um crotchrod story
crotch right sorry i i think you just
said the url wrong to me undies well
let's get it right back it up
it's h3tv you were saying slash h3 let's
run that again it's rewind time
oh i don't think i read this part hold
on back it up rewind hit me with that
music put that music back on me that
says that didn't end
just right for the sponsors this is
still the app kill the ad all
has a great offer for our listeners for
any first time purchase get 15 off and
free shipping right to your door your
days of funding for your life in the
mall parking lot are over to get 15 off
your first order free shipping 100
satisfaction guaranteed go to
meundies.com h3tv
written on the screen
and in the description
that's meundies.com
h3tv
all right
[Music]
oh
shred [ __ ]
all right
beautiful let's look at calls what do we
got um
what do we got
i'm browsing are you brows
uh somebody donated a hundred dollars kd
k.d
peace and love to ela i hope she enjoyed
her birthday
i look forward to the podcast and keep
it on repeat all day she may be watching
right now sometimes watchers first of
all thank you so much we love you this
is a good call this sounds interesting
from emma
okay emma
hi how are you today
i'm good how are you
so as i understand it you are dating
someone with an interesting uh
interest in the bedroom
um well i was dating them um which i
feel like makes it even worse
i
met them on bumble and i was just like
as you do you meet up with someone right
so
uh everything was going good um things
were going in the right direction um
they were nice
and you know things started to get
hot and heavy hold on hold on we're
skipping a lot hold on hold on okay you
went on one date you went on a date
first day first day
you guys went you guys went out for
dinner
um we just like hung out at like a
bookstore you know had some coffee oh
wow
wow yeah so it was nice
okay so so you guys are hanging out at
the bookstore and then somebody suggests
going back to their place
um okay so the thing is i was um still
living with my parents at the time so i
couldn't go anywhere but he
he had a van he had a mom dancing
okay so hold on yeah so wait so you guys
are at the bookstore
and this guy offers to to invite you to
his van
yeah
and um i was just like
whatever
were you a little scared i mean you meet
a guy on you meet a guy on a dating site
and then next thing you know you guys
are going out into his van were you a
little apprehensive
i was a little scared but i feel like um
i definitely could have uh beat him up i
was i was in that kind of situation i
could have definitely handled that oh
all right
where i was going was he a short king
and are you are you like tall what's the
situation there um he was a short king
and i was a little bit bigger than him
you take him in a fist fight
i could totally take him in with this
fight
okay so he so he takes you out to his
van and is it in the parking lot of the
bookstore
uh no we go to it okay he was like hey i
need to go to the bathroom before we go
do anything and i was like okay sure
go do that so he goes to the bathroom
and he grabs his jacket to go in the
bathroom which i didn't think was like a
big thing because you know it was cold
so
he goes in he goes to the bathroom he
comes back and
we go to
a nearby park it's nice it's scenic it's
nighttime
um it's private and
so we start talking and we start kissing
and then one thing leads to another
and i was like okay well maybe now i
should
unbutton his pants as we're taking out
because you know
yeah hold on yes in the car though oh
wait you're in the car okay okay so you
guys are in the van driving around
you're parked
you're parked in the parking lot what
kind of was his van nice i mean how are
we talking about in the van
um it was a chrysler
were you guys in the back of the van
you guys were in the back of it had all
of the uh
uh sea played down uh he had some
blankets you know okay nice
a little cozy okay good so you guys are
making out things are going well
you make the first move
okay
yes and he was into it so okay great i'm
into it too let's do this thing i put my
hands i unbutton his pants and i feel
something strange it's not just normal
boxers right here's the setting by the
way is this look familiar this is where
it all went down right oh wait this is a
plymouth i'm sorry wait hold on we got
to find the van we need to set the
setting right
we're looking for the van this is
important we need to it's a minivan
right chrysler minivan
red
80s 90s
we're tracking this down uh probably
like 2011. okay relatively new 2011 red
chrysler minivan let's go you have his
plate numbers yeah you got his plate
number you got a registration card
this is wonderful okay so we're about to
throw this up here it was red huh damn
okay
so here we go something like this i'm
assuming
okay
were the windows tinted were you afraid
anyone would be able to see in i mean
it's probably deserted but still
um i was a little nervous but i feel
like that's a part of the fun you know
what i mean
absolutely sure that's a hell of a first
date emma i gotta tell you jesus
is a hell of a first date
oh well it gets a little bit better okay
let's let's continue now that we've got
the setting yeah
in that band imagine that
um i open i undo this pants and he's
wearing a diaper
oh
so okay oh
so you open the pants you put your hand
down
how do you realize it's a diaper i mean
you're feeling because you know what
you know what uh underwear feels like
you know and this didn't feel like
underwear so i looked down and i was
like there are there's little animal
print on it
this is a diaper wow
so
not not like a cloth diaper like uh
no like an adult sized adult baby diaper
okay now was he like a was he a thick
guy or like a small guy he was a small
guy we've established skinny yeah he's a
short normal guy wasn't anything crazy
okay so he had some kind of adult
diapers on so what did you say when you
discovered the diaper
i was just like
oh i was so stunned he was like oh do
you have a problem with it i was just
like um
not necessarily
but uh i would have liked to be have
been told this i don't know we don't
keep saying here
um
but
we don't keep we don't kink shame in
this fan
no we don't know this van is a safe
place but like i was just like um so
maybe like i don't want to do anything
and he was like yeah no that's fine i
understand i was like okay cool
why don't you give it a heads up yeah i
know okay so
and then
oh hold on
so you saw the diaper and you
immediately aborted
okay
yes because what would you do no i don't
blame you i'm just trying to get the
facts straight
so i thought i immediately was like
maybe let's not do anything we can still
talk if you want to because i didn't
want to be super mean because
what if like he was crazy you know what
i mean so i was a little
i had to be a little chair so were you
little you were even maybe a little
scared when you saw the diaper eh
definitely um
because i was just like who would do
this on a first date who would do this
to somebody that was on a first date
well yeah because it must be that if he
does it on the first date it must be
that he
gets a thrill out of the shock
that's the only explanation
so what how did he react i didn't know
what to do
i was just like um
and he was just like no like do you like
it like can i call you mommy i was like
no way he said that
he asked if he can call you mommy huh
immediately and i was just like um no
but uh you can still hang out but like
maybe i don't want to go anywhere she's
like okay can i grab something real
quick and i was like uh
oh god what is it
i [ __ ] wish he pulled out a pacifier
and um let's go a blanket animal thing
a lovey i believe those are called
uh-huh and he was just like you hold me
and i was just like are you lying to me
this is
this is called
even ethan i really wish i was lying to
you i really do i don't want to be in i
never wanted to be in that situation
so he kept pushing it after you said no
and he said hold me call me can i call
you mommy and he took out olavian all
this
and this is all going on in the back of
the van okay so so what happens from
that point
so then i was just like dude you gotta
like take me home like i can't do this
like uh and he was just like please come
on no please and i was like no like take
me home right now so he took me home
and that was he did that
okay hold on
so
he's goes back up to the driver's seat
you go back up to the passenger seat is
he still wearing the diaper and stuff
does he change does he put on his pants
did he put on his pants
no he did not
see these are important details so he
drove your ass home in nothing but a
diaper
nothing but a diaper and he was hairy so
it made it even worse
and what did he do with the lovey and
[ __ ] did he bring to leave that in the
back or did he take it up front with
them no he took it up front he knew what
he was doing
and the pacifier
yep pacifier levy diaper was it in his
mouth when he drove you home
no he was just like playing with it in
his hand
and
you gotta ask ethan
you gotta ask
what do i gotta ask i don't know
whatever who's on your mind ain't on my
mind
was there anything in the diaper
oh i assume not dan well i don't know
um
well okay so then
uh he takes me home right and i thought
that was the end of that and like i was
never going to talk to him ever again um
he
gets home i guess and he sends me a
picture and dan was correct
he peed in it he sent you a photo
of his pee diaper
yeah and i can't believe this everybody
and what did you did you respond or what
happened
i said ew and i blocked him
you gave him the u huh
he's probably fishing for it
he likes the human it seems like a
humiliation yeah he likes the
humiliation like why else because like
if you really get the game running so
yeah i think yeah
oh my god um what a disappointing night
for you though because you were he got
what he wanted but you didn't get what
you wanted that's a real violation you
know i feel like did you feel violently
yeah i couldn't
i couldn't tell anybody because like my
i like i couldn't tell my parents
because they were like where were you
i'd be like ah
let me tell you
jesus well have you got have you i
hoping that you had some normal
encounters since then and that uh how
was the second date
yeah did you go to a daycare
yeah i changed his diaper for him and it
was so fun
have you been able to trust men since
then or are you permanently damaged
oh
i definitely have put myself into more
compromising positions but not anything
as intense as that i feel like that was
my biggest one are you what's with these
compromising situations are you are you
into that i mean what's going on with
you emma
no i'm not into that it's just like
i feel like i go after the wrong people
and it's been a pattern
wait
a b
[Laughter]
that he has a red i had this oh i didn't
i did it is this your story
with the [ __ ] balloons attached like
a child's party i mean maybe
this is my favorite let me see
how could you not share this with me
with the glass you have that band
that's your van that's exactly as she
described it a baby
a baby
do you see the band this is it right
that's lit that is it
holy [ __ ] i think i see a pacifier on
the dashboard
hey baby all right emma stay safe out
there okay the next one you may not get
out of there so uh you know what i'm
saying
take care of yourself or something yeah
i'm definitely i don't do that anymore
okay good
where are you when you in college what
are you doing are you uh at home what's
your situation you're 23 okay i'm in my
last year probably not next year's my
last semester graphic design and then
i'm
yeah graduated
but you're able to get some weird ass
out in college no problem you don't have
to like go into parking lots at night
and [ __ ] right that should be easy
like you can get dick out there no
problem
definitely okay good okay good good good
good yeah there's no reason to risk
yourself for a little dick i'm just
telling you
dick comes easy dick dicks a dime a
dozen yeah
yes for sure
you know what i'm saying you don't got
to risk yourself for a little dick all
right
was he wearing pampers or what what was
he what was the diaper
um he said that they were like
specifically made for
like adults so not panthers yeah yeah i
know all right he's great yeah maybe he
knows exactly
all right emma thanks for the call you
take care right thanks thanks for
sharing all right we stan emma
uh the mommy the queen mommy
[Applause]
yeah i had that van for two months and i
[ __ ] loved that thing
in between why why why did you have a
man so there was this big flood in
michigan in 2013 and like it flooded my
engine and so
the insurance company had to give me a
rental and this is all they had because
they had so many cars out so
damn yep
i [ __ ] loved anything wait what kind
of call my white balloon
leno tied those balloons that was the
restaurant we used to work at she tied
it on them
but why
she's just just for fun just lol oh just
for the walls yeah just for the laws
what a coincidence dude
yeah
i'm sorry you feel like you're being
trained my trust but you can't drop that
in the day i'm kidding no i'm kidding
the same color i ever just kidding
this is a real interesting one this
caller from colorado actually has
um
a gripe a beef with me he's angry at
some things i've been saying uh-oh
anonymous are you there hello
yes i am all right are you serious
so what are you angry at me about let's
start there
all right
so
yeah but let's just get to the point
you were you're talking like mad stuff
about the micropenis community bro
[Music]
okay yeah
like
yeah it's it is a medical condition um
and you know i don't want to get too too
angry but yeah
um
what what's what's up
okay no okay no i
i want to hear you out
so okay do you have a you have a micro
penis
yeah
there's something wrong with that no
there's nothing wrong with it what have
i said that's offended you do you
remember i think i have a tremendous um
i have a tremendous empathy for me
before you you know i don't i mean i
know i'm i'm i'm goofing i don't really
care
it's just
anyways but you do have that you do have
that medical condition because i
actually am really curious to ask you
questions but yeah
yeah
so i mean well i don't know if i really
really do like i think i'm like
borderline because like i've looked it
up and i've seen some of this stuff
i mean it is not that you know like
you know we're talking maybe like two
inches you know two inches fully torqued
what did you say yes okay so i mean i
mean and then you see some and it's like
you know it's like barely like it's like
an audi belly button it's not like that
like
you know right it doesn't sound like
it's necessarily micro it's more uh
i think it's i think it's bordering on
micro like you said i think he's right i
the other thing if i might add that you
know might have some interest it is
uncut
does that is that helpful or not at that
size do you think
um
it's not you know i think
part of it is a condition
where it doesn't go past a certain point
because the skin
because i i have a condition
on you know
um
this is like really revealing oh my god
this is a little bit i don't i didn't
think about this go ahead i mean you're
anonymous
you're in a chrysler fan of friends here
yeah
okay safe space right yeah this is
really you know
uncut kings um michael penis kings you
know everybody
i really just wanted to provide support
for them
um
yeah so yeah that's another thing um the
skin is like ingrown to where like you
know like i guess they say like the wood
out grows the bark
the wood out through the bark
so that what's underneath is bigger than
the foreskin
correct
okay
and that anyway that causes some
problems
can i ask you questions can i can i ask
you questions yeah with peace and love
i'm just really curious and if you're
uncomfortable tell me but i have
tremendous respect for the condition you
have i mean i think it's i think it's
you know incredibly difficult and i give
and i tip i tipped the beanie to you
when did you know that you were had like
a a very small penis when growing up did
you know that that was a issue
i mean
porn
oh right i mean i think that's like
yeah well i think with i think we'll
honestly no no okay that's honestly
incorrect my parents actually had to
actually like educate me somewhat you
know like it's basically like you know
clean clean it like it needs to be
cleaned it's different it needs to be
clean they inform me about my condition
i like six
wow
was that in a condition that was
inherited by by any of your parents
like do you know does your dad have that
condition
i mean i don't know i i don't think so
because it's i mean i haven't seen my i
mean is it normal to see your dad's
young yeah at some point when you're a
kid
yeah when i was a kid when i was really
young
i mean i've seen my dad naked when i was
like really young like under five you
know
i don't i don't remember the age but
yeah
but so it's interesting
that's real
that's real interesting they educated
you when you were sick so what'd they
say did they say like son your penis is
different than most people stuff like
that
yeah essentially yeah they're just like
you know there's different methods you
have to clean it like you know like
we don't want you to feel weird about it
like that type of being
so i mean and you know i never thought
it was a weird thing you know they made
it seem normal
i never personally thought it was like a
weird thing until you brought it up like
you never thought it was you never i had
one i couldn't live with myself i'm like
[ __ ] my dad yeah okay you know what i
shouldn't have said that i'm sorry
you know
so that's my beef but yeah i mean that's
you know you don't know
how many people did i say i couldn't
live with myself i think i said i i it
would be very difficult i mean it's it's
a heart condition it's a heart condition
so have have you been intimate with
anybody really i mean
yeah i have and um here's another little
interesting tidbit about me i am like uh
i'm bisexual
and so i haven't really messed up like
anything with the women you know
oh my god should we go that anyways um
let's just say uh i'm giving up the
[ __ ] instead
well that's a great comp well then then
that's great you've made the best of
what you've got yeah
you know
so thank you i feel like you have maybe
even micro penis stolen valor because
the heterosexual guys are really the
ones at the in the front lines in the
trenches i mean you've got that busty
to work with
oh yeah
yeah for sure it definitely gives me an
advantage
uh not many other you know yeah
amazing
incorrect feel good about it
wow well you know what man
any other questions any other questions
you've been dying to know
or well mostly just like about reactions
when people see it when you take your tr
when you drop trial stuff like that
do you tell people do you tell your
partner before
or do you do honestly no i never really
you know i'm not like much of a
relationship guy because of that like i
find it like
because you know like
i don't know
i haven't had any crazy reactions no
just to say short no i haven't and
that's why i'm like maybe i'm not
because i don't know let's if anything
i'm uncooking i don't know about
micro penis but
i mean i honestly don't think it's that
i don't know
it seems like you got some stuff to work
out there
but i'm sorry dude you're you're proof
that you can work it you can live it
especially thank you it's not it's not
like a weird
i don't know like
i never saw it as a weird thing it's not
yeah so yeah and i think you understand
kind of understand like yeah
i'm sorry i shouldn't have said i
couldn't live with that you are you're
working it you're you're living it and
uh
we we love that about you
[Applause]
before this conversation is a lot to
like
handle and you did good you did well the
high chat yeah
we love you all right thank you bro
thanks for calling
apparently uh point six percent of men
worldwide have the condition which uh
there's 7.7 billion people that's a
world so that's 46 million people with
micro penises that's a lot of micropenis
so if you've got a micropenis out there
you're not alone
king [ __ ] venus
short king [ __ ]
um let's see if there's any other
interesting calls something about crotch
rot
is everything gotta be so no no more
crotches for the for the time being
maybe
all right let's let's continue on our
document i want to talk about the
streaming thank you to our callers that
was fun
all right so this stream real quick yeah
this channel
has three million subs
and three million
point six percent of three million is
eighteen thousand
now in all of our not all of our
audience is male 1 let's say let's say
it's like half hold on we have 50 000
people watching so how many people
percentage of them have micro penises
times point zero zero six right
three hundred
do we do micro penises but that's
assuming everybody's male wish to not so
i mean divided by half roughly i mean
there's about 150 micro shout out to 150
people watching with the micro penis you
are loved
you are seen
you can take it in the busy
you can uncircumcise you can circumcise
you can toss it like it's like a tic tac
there's all kinds of things you can do
with it
jiggle it like a dice
we love it
short kings small kings
all right so
let's talk about this does anyone really
care about the streamies i mean really
this is continuously evidently not
because didn't you yeah send a
screenshot of the
so live stream numbers like like 200
people watching no it was 14 000 which
is which is not nothing but you consider
the budget and the they have like every
single person huge and not to take away
from the winners because you know
it's not really about them i understand
you won an award and it's fun and
exciting and maybe i'm just being a
hater ass
we don't care
yeah we don't care
but if you look at the
the thing is is that they wrangle the
biggest creators
and again i don't want to be too much of
a hater because i get the need of
wanting like recognition you know
creators don't get recognition on the
same levels all these [ __ ] who do
these master masturbatory award
ceremonies like the enemies the academy
of wars don't whatever and you know
creators want that recognition too but
the stream is just such a pile of dog
[ __ ]
i mean the awards they they give out
make there's
no uh
sense there's no cohesiveness i mean
last year tana won that doesn't make any
sense for creator of the year
if you go to the sh the highlights
even like the biggest creators in the
world you're talking about markiplier mr
beast's dream they can't even break two
thousand
thirteen thousand on mr beast you know
bella porch a thousand views
and i was watching the live stream the
main live stream it had fourteen
thousand views which again is a lot i
mean it's a lot of people but
they brought all of these people out
here the demilios addison ray brett
rockman you know whatever everybody
bretman i swear i'm not [ __ ] around
bretman rock that's really his name
i feel like brett rockman is better
should he
maybe you should change it yeah
brett rockman
yeah no um
there's just nobody watching this [ __ ]
i just find it real interesting that
nobody watches this [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
so i'm trying to find the main
upload
yeah i mean does it exist anywhere other
than youtube that it might be okay here
it is 13 wait no this is just
this is just a trailer i'm trying to
find the mainstream
of it
does anyone have it
i mean it's starting seven years ago
four years ago
because this year they had like every
freaking celebrity youtube celebrity
there
and
i've always talked [ __ ] about them so i
understand why they snubbed me like our
podcast never wins
wasn't even nominated this year
which is kind of crazy considering we
had like free enemies this year and
we're kind of like i sent you the
mainstream it's got about a half a
million views i mean we had a little ray
hosted it
who oh larae
larae friend of the show friend of the
show
that's what i'm saying though like uh
i mean
look
come on you gotta nominate us right
i mean the competition's stiff
j shetty bro
my boy jay shetty okay so here's the
winners i wanted to go over the winners
and i'm not complaining but i'm just
saying your shit's corrupt bro how many
j shetty fans out there in the chat let
us know hold on we'll shout out to all
the jake
we'll get to jay shetty let's not get
ahead of ourselves
yeah okay so let's just [ __ ] oh
people what do you guys want to pull
about
they wanted a poll about micro penises
or something i told them i already told
you guys no no no microphone
numbers are ready it's done we crunch
the numbers
you want to do a pull how big is your
penis in inches
no i don't want to do that pull
kind of [ __ ] interesting isn't it
yeah
inappropriate if everyone's like super
honest and we do one that's like do you
have a micro penis yes or no
and people will not be honest well not
yeah i'm so honest yes but the inch size
could be interesting i don't know if
that's i mean it's anonymous it's just
science
side note you mentioned tic tacs
you were eating i was eating them as you
said
anyway let's look at this creator of the
year
mr beast one that that makes sense sure
last year
tana beat mr beast
what
i mean nothing against tana i think i
don't know or or against tana i don't
know but
what did she do
i thought she wasn't really even active
on youtube anymore but maybe she was
last year but okay anyway mr beast one
that's good
that one makes sense
show of the year i'm not familiar with
any of this stuff so just good
short form uh breakout creator bella
porch that one makes sense to me friend
of the show friend of the show stan a
queen
stokes twins
stokes twins
wait those are the dudes who [ __ ]
robbed a bank or pretended to rob a baby
you're right
these are the br how are these guys
breakout creators they've been making
videos forever yeah we broke out of jail
these guys have crazy views but that
that's what i mean and that like they'll
these
dude they'll straight up nominate like
can you [ __ ] believe the views on
this [ __ ] what am i missing 37 million
[ __ ] vids
wouldn't love losing
what in the [ __ ] dude i need a cute twin
brother
that formula works on youtube it
definitely does the dolan twins
the stokes twins there's another twins
uh the uh the bread the the dope they
have like uh
the ones that were living in jake paul's
house yeah that's that oh that's them is
that the oh yeah don't know the last
this little spanish twist
[ __ ] you know i need a cute twin brother
for sure [ __ ]
martinez twins yeah there you go
yeah i love them
is that part of some fantasy olivia that
girls have
twins yeah isn't there like a
i've heard of like the male fantasy of
hooking up with twin girls yeah i've
heard that i haven't never heard such
things
really it was like a meme i don't know
growing up i say hear that all the time
and
oh you're joking
okay i
didn't know it was such a big deal in
your life
um but no i have never heard of
two male brother well clearly the proof
that these cute twins people are
pointing out the island boys how can we
forget about the island what's the
island boys
those little cuties can we try to find
like a look-alike for me people thought
it was so serious i thought you were
serious i was so kidding about the
island having the hospital island boys
you were not i was absolutely do not
rewrite history olivia has a certain
type yeah it's a bunch of [ __ ] over
here come on dude they're a little pete
davidson they're a to little pete
davidson
[Music]
lives on a different like
he lives in a different universe than
the island boys that i understand that
there are similarities there and it's
they are the exaggerated version of some
of
the like niches of boys that i tend to
have a crush on however you're
writing history i'm not
we all knew you were serious i don't
want to talk about this anymore okay all
right we'll move on
okay
um crossover uh shout out to will smith
for his
crossover ah
beating up bill gates bill [ __ ] gates
yeah bill gates didn't butter they're
big enough
for night
it was epic
the epic youtube video where bill gates
uh
implied he had epstein killed
what did bill gates do on youtube
actually seriously well he died he died
so yeah
is there any what have you learned from
epstein that you would maybe uh you know
well he died
so
he does this with his hands he spreads
them a lot well he died
let's look at bill's channel like
seriously what what the [ __ ]
bill got 20 000 views what a loser
[ __ ] loser
here's a one minute clip reasons for
optimism after a difficult year
[ __ ] you're the one that had a
difficult year yeah well 2021 would say
well 20 21.
well you know my life's like good friend
epstein uh
he video gamed himself and well
you know
it was up to me that wouldn't have
happened was there jail that made the
[ __ ] water was that him yeah yeah
[Music]
the
just a nice little youtube video i made
and you know shot myself
you know i nobody else worked on this i
edit it's a nice little video
got like a whole [ __ ] pr team for
this the
pandemic
the need to get going on climate change
all these things were tough
but i'm optimistic about accelerating
innovation in the climate area who gives
a [ __ ] i'm optimistic about the work why
did you make this video
he's got a lot of pr crossover event of
the year my friends he's got a lot of
image improvement he's got to do global
health building on some of the pandemic
innovations
i think
2022 will be the year in which many of
us settle into a new normal
so i think we'll build on the the good
stuff
i see you know that now now that epstein
is is gone it's a time for a new normal
okay and uh
the island is gone
we had a lot of fun at that island
we'll find a new island we'll get by
[Laughter]
and it'll be a new normal for us
and i'm excited that we will take the
steps to avoid another pandemic like
this one happening again
oh don't show that that's not good
that's not what you want to see when
you're talking about a pandemic
just like hordes of people like come on
now bill
where's the social distancing
you can read my entire year in review
at
gatesnotes.com guess what nobody's
reading that [ __ ]
[ __ ] bill gates you can check it out
for the flight records
i just want to say that the flight
records are not 100 accurate
it said i wrote on his plane 20 times i
just want to say the flight records are
maybe it was only you know three
what other videos has bill gates made
five ideas for summer reading why are
people watching this [ __ ] my favorite
author's book accessible book to date
literally why is anyone watching this
um
they're all so short too
he got he's got a real social crack team
on this
my favorite author's book
flush within oh here's the poop water
video
ten years ago our foundation challenged
the world to reinvent the toilet
to raise awareness of this challenge
i've shared a stage bro come on this is
mine
bill gates could show a cup full of
doo-doo and i can't [ __ ]
i've taken a giant whiff a pit latrine
odor i took a big old whiff of [ __ ] okay
i'm a man of the people down my leg
i went to a porta potty in a third world
and i took a big whiff of [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] my pants all right
so you know
i drink water made from fecal sludge and
i convinced some friends i made i drank
fecal sludge
what a nice word by the way
why is this a thing i had a uh i had a
local ugandan take a big ol [ __ ] in a
glass for me
then i turned it into fecal sludge and
drank it
friends to drink it too
thank you buddy
all of these stunts got some laughs but
my goal was to draw attention to a
serious problem poor sanitation
more than 500 000 people die every year
from sanitation related diseases but
this problem can be solved in the decade
since the launch of the reinvent the
toilet challenge the world has responded
the power of innovation creative minds
from across the globe developed hundreds
of new and exciting ideas for how to
design toilets i mean i love the project
does good i do like the project i have a
photo of um bill doing some
some hands-on research
we put a special out we put a special
party
you know and i i had a special viewing
spot to make sure that the experiment
was going properly fecal [ __ ]
you know people expelled the fecal
matter right into my uh test area
i love goofing on bill gates
yeah what the [ __ ] is this headline okay
so this year
bill gates adventure aims to spray dust
into the atmosphere to block out the sun
what is he [ __ ] uh yeah he's doing
this in sweden wait what's the name of
that the villain from the simpsons mr
burns mr burns did this
what is why is he doing this
i don't know climate change
i guess yep
to block okay so if we block the sun
isn't it the plot of the matrix
uh that is how they initially tried to
defeat the machines yes
which led to the matrix right kind of
idiots well it's kind of good in a way
that we're
developing the technology to take out
the robots eventually
he's getting out of the curve he knows
something we don't clearly and we like
that we love that about him
anyway
talk about a steamer back to the steamy
oh
nice so will smith took down that
crossover
congrats first person finally will smith
getting some recognition in the industry
he needed this yeah so live streamer
valkyrie i don't know much about her
but
i guess good she had a big uh skin care
controversy
i'm sure she does a lot more than that
but
i'm afraid that's the only thing i've
heard about
i think she backed out of that product
yeah i think she she'd okay here so
here's a podcast okay
i love barely bailey sirian
she won that's the winner yeah okay so
shout out
but i love h3 podcast more yeah
[Applause]
maybe you don't have to whisper i'm just
i'm totally kidding
[Applause]
[ __ ]
okay well guys this was like the biggest
year in hd podcast history with
frenemies we were like number 12 in the
whole country
yeah yeah
world i mean anything sure but so you
know i mean impulsive okay at least they
didn't win
what is dark history you listen to this
yeah bailey sarien does um
she has something called murder mystery
and makeup where she talks about murder
cases while she does her makeup and dark
history is her podcast where she doesn't
do her makeup while she's talking and
she talks about like
unknown
dark historical
you know stories
i was thinking honestly of next year
working on launching a true crime
podcast
i love
crime and i was thinking of just getting
i love true
like a new team to could produce it
because it's a lot sorry dan
no that's okay i hate true kind people
yes i really do but you would manage it
you would make sure it gets done for
sure yeah
but getting a team to like um
research it put it together because it's
a lot of work sure and then um
we can just narrate it
i'd be so down to help with that and i
think you guys could participate and
like because i i really like when they
i really like when they get into
character
so another person can speak when they're
doing the character of someone else
it's not like
a play but sometimes you're recounting a
transcript or something
right it's true crime there's players
like i love radio bro listen i love true
crime so i know i'll bring the heat
yeah olivia you be you're into that so
you'll be good for that i love
you can be the girl that dies every time
perfect
you can be the guy that dies every time
people are saying the market's so
oversaturated i don't give a [ __ ]
it really is there's so many nobody does
it like me
nobody does it like me
well anyway at least but the funny thing
is that there's this guy jay shetty
shout out to shetty
where's my shitty heads out there shout
out to my shitty
heads um if you don't like it don't
watch it you know what i mean our
schedule will stay the same i mean you
don't have to watch it i think it'll be
really good though because i love it
and um
that's it it'll be fun you know be an
interesting new vertical to get into
diversify
right you got to diversify these pods
wait this is jeffrey's new place
for real
what in the god's name
damn he's down bad dude
i thought it was real pretty
i think he owns all the land around it
too i'm sure i'm coming for you jeffrey
just saying he's going to be soon all
right right i forgot about that
it looks like where heisenberg went to
go hide out after the fbi was after him
oh yeah
so there's a guy jay seti can you shetty
can you find him he's pronounced shitty
can you find his win history
uh oh in previous steamies yeah yeah
well so jake
whatever
shetty this shitty who nobody knows who
is
i've never heard of tons of [ __ ] shitty
heads out there i don't know anything
about i've never heard of him i don't
recognize faye don't see him he is like
the darling of the podcast category
of the steamies
and you can see the views are insane
even demi lovato came on and got 27 000
views
apparent somebody told me he's really
big on facebook yeah well everybody is
logic
78 000 logic's a shitty head
yeah i didn't know he was a shitty head
huh
uh yeah 2020. i mean look at these
guests though hassan minaj he won over
us right because we weren't we were
nominated yeah pull it up put it on
screen
yes you were nominated last year
and the set the shetty took the dub
we're like who the [ __ ] is jay shetty
i expected david dobrik or something or
impulsive to win
nah the dark horse
and then shitty himself
and then the year before he was
nominated or won didn't he
uh let me see 2019
the shitty himself they love this
[ __ ] guy
they're all they're big shitty heads
over at the streamies he was the host of
this dreamy purpose awards in 2018.
what is this guy is like connected dude
the [ __ ] runs deep bro
you know there's something fishy about
the shitty this [ __ ] had oprah
on a 2019 impulsive one over us and
jason wait impulsive one in 2019 yeah i
didn't even realize that
guys come on you know that's [ __ ]
this [ __ ] got oprah on
okay that one did well that one had 680
thousand views
but i'm just saying bro there's
something shitty in the water
bill gates is
um
you know it's
will smith now that's a crossover event
2018. wait he wasn't even nominated
phone did this guy really title his kobe
bryant interview kobe bryant's last
great interview
you
that's pretty bad
that's disgusting that's some freak [ __ ]
sorry what
well he was a big shetty say okay
kobe bryant's last great interview
what's the date i can't see it it was
september 18 2020.
didn't you wait he died in january of 29
in january he died on my wedding day
yeah he reposted this and i see labelled
it as kobe bryant's last great interview
good click bait
that's disgusting that's awesome beyond
clickbait that's that's really gross
am i wrong thinking that's really gross
no
damn somebody said that's not his last
one yeah it's not his last one but it's
his last great it's his last great one
uh it's gross
it's his other ones were [ __ ]
his legacy is basically this interview
oh for sure if there's one thing we want
it's for jay shetty
interview with kobe who is jay shetty
why is he interviewing all these jay
shetty is the host of
uh
shetty
the shetty how did he how did he land
how does he land all these interviews he
has over 300 i'm sorry 30 million
followers on facebook yeah he's in uh i
believe he's like a
former motivation guy
i think it's kind of you know oh the
motivation [ __ ] is
a garyvee
does he sell crypto he's an english
author former hindu monk and life coach
of indian descent oh god
there's nothing worse than life coaches
and he has a book called think like a
monk
yeah aka kobe bryant's last great
[ __ ]
i swear there's nothing worse than life
coaches life coaches i only know one
thing how to enrich themselves
[Music]
that's pretty shitty can we do a poll
how many people know who jay shetty is
before this podcast have heard or know
who the [ __ ] this is
by the way they never nominated joe
rogan by the way who before spotify was
on youtube
but jay shetty on facebook taking the
dubs all day
who the [ __ ] is j shetty let's see
paul's coming then
the [ __ ]
no 88
no
dude
wait why am i not saying yes as an
option am i
okay never mind
89
no
you know
i mean
this nut this is just a brutal snub
impulsive
that [ __ ]
uh
i'm not going to say junkie that would
maybe it's incense jesus
but i mean he's kind of a douche at
least we could say that i mean like i'm
not oh no i'm a strawberry
he's a maverick i'm surprised they
didn't uh nominate uh david dobrik's
podcast he posted like one episode
i saw he in one of them i forgot which
one one of the previous years where we
were nominated uh dobrick's
podcast was also nominated
yeah so um we both lost
we were nominated like four times in a
row
i never begged my our followers to go
brigade there them with like begging
them to vote for us or something i don't
know if it's user
voted or what
i think so
i think it's a fan vote kind of thing
um 90 no i mean that's that's real
interesting to me j shetty but the
shetty takes the dubs forever
shout out vsauce3 friend of the show
took a dub there
bret man rock took a dub hey you got it
winners are determined by independent uh
judging body of creators executives and
other experts oh really who's on that
who's on that board
keemstar and ryan kavanagh
expert youtube viewers i'm sorry but h3
podcast took the dub this year i'm just
going to say it you know yep like i'm i
i'm not look i'm i'm i don't like to
flaunt my achievements or whatever but i
feel like to not even get nominated is
some real doo-doo dog [ __ ] and i don't
care about this this big old steamers
but this year we we've been making four
shows a week true
pulling
consistent numbers
frenemies came
which was a sensation
this year we worked so hard
you know
and
not to numb what the expert who are
these experts
it might be because you made the
steamies i think you announced that
you're making it despite the streamies
oh yeah that's what i'm saying but
listen if you're going to get better
that we're goofing on you what kind of
award show are you right
that's not impartial dude
yeah so we did the steamy so what and
we're gonna do it again this year so
buckle the [ __ ] up
has that been announced
prior to this moment well here it is
steamies are coming
uh and when was it uh ian when were we
planning to do it
it'll be in january when we come back uh
date to be determined
so the steamies are coming and i'm gonna
take a big old steamer on the
steamies it's a [ __ ] award show and
nobody watches it either the steamies
has better viewership
hold the [ __ ] phone
the steamies
uh frenemies
episode so we determined their
their show had half a million
okay well you want to know something the
steamies has 4.1 million so what the
[ __ ] do you want
i'm the steamies now we just j shetty
all over the streamies i'm the you know
what i'm gonna make a category for worst
awards
show and guess who's gonna win
interesting interesting guess he's gonna
win that [ __ ] oh you know i'll put
another one uh lowest viewed award show
let's do like 10 categories most unfair
award show
most corrupt award show guess who's
gonna win all of those
your girl bailey uh serene sorry in one
serion shout out
wanna give a fan
queen
damn gus johnson was nominated for
comedy i think they missed the memo on
that one
uh linta dong i'm not sure who that is
do you know who that is
nope
they won't best comment oh it's a tick
tock account
yeah a lot of them are tick tockers oh
wow 17 million followers
it's do you want to watch one here easy
how many this one has 5.5 million
when you told her to dump his ass
multiple times but now you are attending
their wedding
okay
well i mean okay
not gonna try not to hate on every
single [ __ ] thing for this one
that's 41 million
nobody shy guy with ring lights
all right
congratulations
to
uh
lena dong
for winning best comedy
nobody guy on my for you page with ring
light i'm pretty sure you just did this
joke but let's see
[Music]
let's see is it the roles again or are
we gonna do something else
me for all those guys have those crazy
ass edits
let's tic talk edits with the ring light
sure
okay awesome super
funny stuff
here's one with uh uh
10 million
i heard we were sharing our alter egos
she got a calm
oh hey look at her
damn
she cleans up well folks
we love that
super
awesome
interesting stuff
30 million
this girl i saw this she has a bagel
cutting machine
uh she thinks it's unnecessary i'm
assuming oh here play the audio at the
very end there let's see what she says
i just cut this way then chop my fingers
off like i'm stuck
okay
awesome fantastic
wow
incredible stuff guys what can i say we
honor the best and the brightest amongst
us
um
let's find one more loving it here's one
four million
that's not her i guess she's face to
lock through that it was out of space
contrary to belief if you didn't hold up
your hair i don't know if you would fit
i don't know but this is my life
can you imagine hanging out with her be
like this video let's go
i don't know
i don't know
you can literally go through i don't
know
i don't know okay this one's kind of
funny i have an idea
i'm gonna walk sideways like a crab your
hair is not gonna get stuck if you walk
through it's not gonna
oh
what a fact
[Music]
the hair is pretty funny how she lifts
her area
okay well hey congratulations hello
chuckle at me on that one absolutely
a real talent a tour de force you might
even say and we love that
right
don't we love that
commentary drew goodin
shout outs
good guy i really like drew gooden's
videos i like him
dance i mean okay i'm not the
jabberwockies oh yeah every year
jeff widdick took home the documentary
series
don't try this at home
uh about how david dobrik tried to blind
him
and um
well
he took home an award there was all
kinds of interesting media about it one
there
so people are saying someone is live i'm
not guys okay
stop stop i'm not going to watch trisha
moses live
this is not the time
now is not the time
we already pushed it far enough with the
wedding gag
[Laughter]
where now is not the time
uh
the media jeff posted was pretty funny
though i don't know if you guys want if
you can dig up some of that
okay ethan
okay jeff
yeah contra uh contra points is a friend
of the show that's nice that she was
nominated
i think that's cool
robbed
some may say that sure damn just me
that's my opinion wade jarvis
is this the guy
okay i was like is that faze jarvis
no
okay
jab you know who jabberwocky is for
dance olivia
sorry what
they're the dudes with the white masks
they've been around forever yeah they
have a residency at universal studios
yeah
they they've been around a very long
time
interesting
awesome yeah they've been on top of the
day and they've been probably ten years
the dance pretty cool i guess i mean i
don't really know anything about dance
but all right we got some jeff whitake
uh he he's super stoked i mean you know
congratulations to him again
not trying to be a douche about
everything in life but i guess i just
can't help myself
ex dope
x dope dealer turned award-winning
documentary filmer well okay tone it
down a little bit it's the steamies
i mean it's not cans
i liked the documentary
yeah it was nice
just saying
not steven spielberg
i mean these days even steven
spielberg's not steven spielberg when's
the last time that guy came in a good
movie what's that story came out like
just saying this week
[Laughter]
did you see it is it any good no i can't
wait stephen spielberg made the west
side story
the new one yeah i'm so excited what a
weird choice for a directorial
it looks beautiful good reviews yeah 93
run tomato wow i was also surprised to
find out that i mean has he done
musicals before
is this his first uh
actually i mean he does action movies
and [ __ ]
or whatever
and high drama
but yeah i don't know if he's ever
i mean maybe he has maybe i'm just
forgetting but rip to the goat stephen
sondheim
oh yeah he just died like a month ago
the goat
the goat i'm saying it's his first
musical
huh
look at that
i love the original
even if it's extremely problematic in
today's world
i love wesson's story but it's a great
movie
yeah i heard um steven
steven spielberg after that he's got
lined up um
he'll be directing uh
the muppet movie so
that's huge that would be awesome i know
you're trying to do a joke but i i would
love to try to think of something he'll
be doing uh he'll be
he's directing a comedy
actually his next it's his first just
purely in space
pure comedy no it's actually
that
collaboration with the tick talker that
we just watched it's going to be awesome
schindler's list in space
it's an avant-garde take on the old
classic yeah
yeah
pretty interesting one
all right fashion style do we like this
olivia i'm not familiar with any of
these people wisdom k i don't know who
that is actually okay i don't watch a
lot of fashion stuff
dream one gaming dubs dubs dubs
hell yeah dude hold on
doctor mike one that's the kova doctor
won it two years in a row for help
dr mike should win the award for covet
super spreader not health and wellness
how are they gonna
how are they gonna give it
to dream
because he cheated
it's not a competitive game it's just
gaming content hell yeah hell yeah how
did everybody like that was the most
embarrassing thing ever how did
everybody get on a speed run i mean it's
not
yeah
i mean who cares about that honestly but
it was the like
oh
he hired us
you know hiring statisticians to prove
that he didn't he didn't do it he went
to like the mit institute to hire a
mathematician approved so insane the
let's go
it's true
it is true it was pretty funny how could
you give it to that guy
he has had a huge year though i mean
he posted a video 12 days ago of a
minecraft speed run
and by the way these titles just like
the most unclick bait titles ever like
minecraft speedrun version five hunters
finale rematch with a really ordinary
looking thumbnail and he pulled in the
views on this show oh yeah no i mean
that's mega popular so i must i'm not
into this kind of content but he must be
really good at it
so oh my gosh yes
the lebron fam took the family kids and
family i'm sorry this this should not be
an award in fact it should be banned
these [ __ ] it took me to a 404
page
what happened to the lord
are you [ __ ] serious
you know that no i think i was joking
you could tell it's a [ __ ] up url look
at underneath it has slash https guys
come on
brandts are the ones that we talked
about recently on the show that uh
clickbaited their kid having cancer yes
no don't you [ __ ] say that yeah
seriously it's them yeah yeah it's them
no
way
no
way okay so you know now they're just
participating in
the exploitation of kids
basically
you know
there's a writer post that has the
original thumbnail in it still i know
that's interesting to look at but
there's a subreddit called lebron fam
snark
jesus
uh it's just a subreddit dedicated to
hating them yeah she got diagnosed with
cancer premier documentary this [ __ ]
should not only exclude you from awards
but get you banned
from [ __ ] making more videos with
your family in it was somebody in the
chat is this true that they had the real
they sold the realistic baby i think
that was a different family
because that was like a british family
that sold
the like remember they made like a
super realistic one of their babies
this was the first thumbnail and this
was the second like this second one is
way worse
i agree jesus the second one is way
worse
the [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
yeah so sh i guess hey
family of the year
yeah by the way uh youtube family
channels have a really good track record
of uh
no
controversy or scandals
by the way the huge family channel what
was their name like from years they were
the biggest family channel on youtube
good
attwood rominator no not roman atwood he
was even before him
you're talking about the one that you
made videos about i'm not
no he it ended up he was like drunk
texting like
peace stars and sex workers and try and
like cheating and a drunk the shadow now
let's see it was uh
yeah the shade
[Laughter]
yeah
the shaytards is that the family whose
son died and then they kept no vlogging
no
there was a family whose son died and
they like vlogged the day that he died
and the day after no that's too sad i
can't deal with that it was really yeah
those [ __ ] really named their
channel shaytards
love that well ethan i gotta say we're
the number one family channel you know
family family family family family
family family family family
family family family
family family family family family
family family family family
anyway
yeah and of course they're like super
conservative christians so
go ahead and click bait your
child dying you [ __ ] freaks
yeah i'm sure this is what the real life
is like
oh my god
i'm sure that he doesn't get sometimes
drink a little too much
let's let's
i'm sure the life is just perfect
maybe maybe the views drip a little bit
and all of a sudden we're talking about
maybe one of our kids is dying of cancer
i'd see that i i feel like he probably
doesn't drink at all
oh really guy like that daddy as [ __ ] he
definitely works out
that guy drinks
i don't know these like
i like beer you know like kavanaugh kind
of no christian family they kick it back
they get he kicks it back and having
some beers with friends
bloody crap i mean blood i mean wine is
the blood of christ right we drank beer
jesus turned water to wine i mean that's
a lush right there i mean jesus himself
was like don't [ __ ] drink water drink
wine
jesus
hell yeah brother you know
how do you argue with that
i love the
brandt family
100 million what is this this one this
got a hundred million views
four-year-old girl and daddy do cutest
carpool karaoke ever
by the way he titled that about himself
and by the way that here's a red flag
sorry
i no disrespect to men with long hair
it's just the way he's got it styled
it's just odd
what uh
what are you trying to say dog nothing
wrong about your hair his hair not yours
there's something about his hair
i think you've got to agree that that's
a red flag haircut the feathered [ __ ]
it's just something about it ain't right
but can you imagine titling your own
video that listen to the radio
sure
and he said
yep
[Music]
it's too much what
i said that's taylor swift
[ __ ] this ain't no improvised
[ __ ] you got in a different costume
every time
yo i can't hate on his hair dog i'm
sorry you love that hair i think his
hair's dope
okay that's what zach was you know
what's wrong you know what's the hair is
he's trying to make it look rockstar but
don't doesn't he have like highlights
and [ __ ] and it's all like blown drying
and yeah you know
okay
i can't hate on it
i'm not laughing at you i'm not getting
red flags from this
oh man
this isn't okay i'm out
i'm out i'm out i'm out anyway
congratulations to them
nobody can compete
shout out to captain disillusion friend
of the show
didn't win for veritasium one he's got a
good channel
lifestyle
addison ray taking the dub
hey ray
oh this was huge news channel five won
an award let's go and also hassan was
nominated it's almost no name phillyd
i don't know why they throw hassan in
news and not
live streaming but okay i mean he does
news
you know what's interesting yeah he won
news last year
yeah that's right
let's ride
channel 5 isn't really news it's more
like journalism but i'm happy he won
science marc roper sports whatever
technology whatever cinematography
talking about youtube videos come on
editing
i thought this was weird logan paul's
editor was nominated
he's gotta cut around a lot of [ __ ] i
just realized
that's a good point i just realized
casey neistat's brother's on there
oh yeah oh
interesting let's see
that's his brother mm-hmm
well god it doesn't even look anything
like him
yeah i think it's his that's the beard
and no hair he's flipped i think
he maybe he's half brother or something
i don't remember he is a good editor
look at this [ __ ] did he win this video
includes a paid promotion might actually
be a paid promotion in and of itself
who won he did that hbo series casey
right amy so i'm going i believe this is
like casey
i mean their studios looks like yeah so
the two of those guys used to be like uh
producers and stuff for for mainstream
media
so wait a cooking show one best editing
let's see what the [ __ ] lynn davis has
got going on
oh it's tick tock okay
[Music]
okay this is pretty cool
fluff it up pour it in and mix till
thick pretty high effort
especially the stick the bow tie filler
up top with whipped cream and add a face
oh his head got deflated snowman
milkshake that was good
these cookie monster cookies are the
most insane cookies you'll ever have
let's see if it's busting or not
[Music]
yeah like this to be honest
i'm gonna watch this later
baby
certified busting these cookie monster
cookies
cool
there you go shout outs to uh cooking
with lin
on tick tock
zach king of course takes the dub
nobody really does editing better than
him he's pretty next level
game theorist uh
writing
honorable mention i couldn't even get an
honorable mention
social good award
um bill gate no i don't know
activation activision yeah oh this is
the way okay whoa whoa whoa hold on hold
on everybody slow down
everybody slow down
i forgot this is my favorite part
this is my absolute favorite part of
this of the steamies this is when we
thank our corporate overlords
comp okay so check this out company or
brand
best brand award goes between png
activision
and state farm
who gives a [ __ ]
who the [ __ ]
cares this is the
most
[ __ ]
disgusting corporate [ __ ] suckery i've
ever seen the call of duty
yo state farm had a huge year this year
well this isn't uh
this one is for um
for like charity work
specifically right
like these are all yeah these are all
charity uh
so it's not because there is another one
that we were talking about last night
that is just like straight up like
company of the year or whatever we're
getting there right too bad they don't
have best lawsuit
[Laughter]
advocate yeah
um
creator okay jace jay said he was
nominated
wow for help india breathe let them
breathe let's see let them breathe
assume that's like an air quality thing
help india breathe
just let them breathe
no so is uh
for oxygen for like icus let them
breathe dude oh that's okay it sounds
like it is a good thing during covet i
remember they ran out of oxygen yeah
so good shout outs jay to shetty
who's
letting them breathe out there beautiful
india
nonprofit or ngo
whatever
okay so this one gets really good now
this is just brand of the year
disney plus
doritos
mattel
target
or warner bros and a huge congrats to
target
for taking the w this year brand of the
year
by streamies let's see let me click it
oh it just takes you to target
shout out [ __ ] awesome
that is just incredible guys dude
doritos [ __ ] fell off can you believe
that that they got [ __ ] owned by
target dude mattel got robbed this year
those new barbies they brought out yo
yo that dream house dude
brand of the year target took it down
you guys
[ __ ]
what happened to doritos though man
they just well they were nominated at
least you know
yeah not creator brand it's a legacy
number rant of the year what the [ __ ]
bro target
what the [ __ ] is this you were
embarrassing
agency of the year okay i mean who gives
a [ __ ] uh
brand as creator
brand
as creator okay the washington post
really [ __ ] gets me
yeah everybody's favorite creator the
washington post
what the [ __ ] by the way
mattel is obviously paying them a lot of
money because barbie was nominated
netflix
poopoori
spongebob squarepants took the dub
and of course what the the real dark
horse the washington post
yeah it was amazing
yeah
everyone's favorite creator
brand engagement
shout out to ooh
cash app took the dub but hot pockets
was in a close damn neck and neck race
hot markets
oh yeah hot pockets i've
i've i haven't heard of that brand in a
long time
hot pockets yeah like i feel like they
fell off unless i'm wrong plus ratio
brand engagement [ __ ] hot pockets
or cash app
branded series
let bruh
target one branded series let's target
huge shout out
we gotta see that let's check out the
target show this is a huge dub my
friends
i think it's really funny that lara jean
is such a baker when i found out you're
not a baker i was like oh my god she
deserves an oscar for her performance
[Music]
let's get baked
with targeted
okay and we're going to line it with our
liners i've learned to double the liner
because you know how sometimes like the
back literally an advertisement so does
that mean you're going to target a glue
gun
um i know the girl on the left was in to
all the boys i loved before name's lana
condor
to all the brands i loved before
[Music]
well
huge [ __ ] dub for target what is it
late night taste buds with doritos they
made us
there's something going on where why are
these brands making five parts series
lift comics lift
okay
at least this one has kevin hart or
something i don't know
but that's more than what triller's got
trailer does notably does not have no
kevin hearts on driller well let's watch
this doritos seven part series or five
part series rather
doritos
dillas and dixie demilio
one of the biggest hello everybody
welcome to late night taste buds i'm
your host jc caleb and i am your co-host
co-host kian lolly can you like wait no
i'm the host the other guy's michael
reality house
i mean
300 000
views be worse not a lot though for how
much they probably spent on this and
paid them yesterday dixie demilio
i doubt dixie shows up to something like
this without like a quarter million
bucks being i'm serious
you know jc and i are professional cooks
and you guys have been sending in so
many of your own recipes so today we're
making don't care
[Music]
um
oh here let's see what mattel has been
all over this dude
here's a barbie series
[ __ ] they want something all out
wow this one's probably the most views
today on barbie youtube hundred thousand
thousand damn anything i thought maybe
kid audience to learn about astronauts
can be anything today we're going to
meet some young girls who want to follow
their dream okay this is kind of nice
content for our kids actually
and also like who the [ __ ] wants to
watch
this is nice i have no problem with this
this is nice content i like i appreciate
nice content for the kids
branded video
who cares bro amazon prime
discord the movie oh and then by the way
i know i didn't even know this was a
category but creator product okay so
this is like creator brand
[ __ ] knelt one
for their hard seltzer
nice
i'm surprised roubet didn't win
right
and again you know at teddy fresh you
know i'm not gonna complain but like i
feel like that's a pretty big creator
brand you know i mean you didn't play
ball with the streamies you can't have
it both ways i mean right now
oh god
you gotta play ball with these people
i'm gonna go rip a dart
but like now boys they're such pieces of
[ __ ] and it's an alcohol
all right
shut up milk boys
influencer campaign tied super bowl yeah
shout out tide uh
they need awards these uh target really
needs recognition here
so
you know ultimately what the [ __ ] this
[ __ ] is so dumb it has been so dumb it
remains so dumb everyone saying hollow
taco was robbed
that's yeah simply nailogicals nail
polish
oh okay
hollow taco ela wasn't even nominated i
mean come on
that's something i didn't play ball
it doesn't matter if they're if they're
reputable
no they're not they're not you think
nelk played ball what the [ __ ] did nelk
ever do
think so
probably for sure shout it out
they'll tag them in a social post or
whatever
they won't go out of their way to [ __ ]
all over them like we do so
yeah we'll [ __ ] them
i hope brian cavanaugh sues them
for not nominating him as the
creator of the year creator of the
creator brand of the year
driver of the year
oh you know we should do a category for
steamies
most person that most looks like harvey
weinstein oh
i think i know who might have that one
in the bag
that was fun huh
definitely
and then there's actually
there's a lot of calf cab updates i
don't know if you all [ __ ] there's a
lot of cav cab updates this guy does not
stop
we're
just about at three hours yeah let's
wrap it up
you can save it for wednesday to see if
there's anything really
i don't know
one of his posts got removed for like
harassment
that is pretty awesome harassing me
isn't that awesome yeah oh did you see
what olivia just said
oh bailey
sarian follows me
should i i'll follow her back
she's a friend of the show collab
the winner of the prestigious best
podcast of the year we love a bridge
building queen we love a bridge building
oh yeah everybody i'm about to become
our competitor though in the true crime
space
let's get in there and get some we love
them we love a bridge burning king
bridge burning
i am a bridge burner what the [ __ ] i
just typed
okay her name and it's just showing me
random fan [ __ ] okay here she is bailey
sarian
shout out bailey
if you're watching this
um
i'm following you back and now we're
friends bailey where's teddy fresh says
somebody oh no way
she's the best i love her we love that
we love bailey she's awesome huge
congrats to her for her big one she
deserved it
she deserved the what can we say she's
got the better podcast
well yeah i mean i mean shut up you know
i love the genre i love everything you
do
your makeup is incredible
i do my makeup while she does her makeup
when i turn her videos
i mean a friend a friend of olivia is a
friend of ours
period no cap no cap
none no busting or yes bussing
we bust him
we are busing
we are bussing
um anyway this was pretty funny just
kind of a little capcaf thing yeah he
kept posting like a bounty on me and
talking all this smack and kind of
craziness it's funny he keeps saying how
how like we're responsible for him
getting harassed we're telling people to
ask him this is the he's the only one
getting his posts removed for [ __ ]
community guidelines
i haven't had any posts removed about
that i should have said about him
but he's out on instagram wilding the
[ __ ] out
and
they said we've removed ryan kavanagh
officials post because it goes against
our community guidelines you know i mean
what
dude you're the one violating rules here
that's not a good look bro his algorithm
is getting crushed i've had not one
thing i've said about you get removed
for community guidelines strikes or
anything so
not a good look kavkev i guess i did
something to piss off the instagram god
top comment now just wait for the next
post to include that he's that i've been
paying off instagram to remove his posts
and wants to add them to the lawsuit
that was his first thought i'm sure
actually if you go to his um wikipedia
page
some [ __ ]
the mods there have been like really
holding it down man
he there's been people trying to revert
all the ch how do i get to the um
dude i really should i should really
donate to wikipedia i was thinking
wikipedia is so freaking amazing there
are no ads do you know how amazing that
is there's no ads it's just information
there's no pop-ups it's just it's such
an amazing website
can you donate from our card
uh sure what should we give like i don't
know
what are they asking for they're asking
for 275. we can definitely donate that
let's do
let's do 500 bucks
500 bucks
i'm gonna keep wikipedia running for
decades we need wikipedia oh you guys
kids they are a non-profit
they operate this [ __ ] website for
the good of humankind i mean
they really are just incredible
there's no ads it's it's it's such an
amazing website it really is
you're doing that right now dan
thank you
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
we're doing it you got me this time
wikipedia
yes so
there's been a shitload of editors
trying to revert the changes that some
people did
it's pretty incredible man like let's
see
it's kind of hard to read this like in
the matrix
i don't even know what the [ __ ] going
on oh wow
but one person here
who i have no association with ryan if
you're watching
added a section that i thought was
pretty cool
was really good uh good information
wait how the
freak do i go to this
oh my god can anyone make sense of this
um filling out the
thing right now
oh here we go so i think they added this
was a new paragraph i noticed well
researched
if you go to
um
personal life other ventures
yeah they added a career other ventures
it says kavanaugh
oh thank you so much guys yes and and
really thank you wikipedia for
i mean
this is a website that really serves the
the public interest
it's incredible you can include
wikipedia in your will would you like to
do that
uh and [ __ ] no
what
this got weird that's a hard sell let's
let's tone it down
you can leave us everything when you die
chill dude bit odd yeah chill all right
uh what are you trying to figure out i
can here i found it okay this was a
paragraph that was recently
added i think the other
the other ventures
in 2017 kavanaugh found investment
proximity media with blah blah blah
yeah approximately required a majority
stake in trailer
signing of the trump admins announcing
is this what they added um
so they say after attempting to acquire
the hollywood stock exchange 2019
kavanaugh set out to create a similar
trading exchange and tapped elon sappar
who formerly works
for the owner uh yeah exactly of hsx
to help him in the venture the two
formed
an entertainment
stock x in june 2019 spar
who had been esx ceo submitted a lawsuit
against kavanaugh for fraud claiming
that he was misled into believing that
kavanaugh's company proxima media had
the necessary capital for esx spars suit
alleged that kavanaugh was essentially
running a ponzi scheme kavanaugh was
count
was countersuing spar alleging that spar
was breaching his contract with esx
kavanaugh and spar reached an agreement
and withdrew their lawsuit so that's a
pretty good
it's fantastic summary of it
yeah
i think even ryan would think that was
fair
i mean
it's it's a thing that happened
it's a thing that was alleged yeah but
there's all the all all the greatest
hits here now pretty interesting
litigation more of the more of this uh
man he really [ __ ] up
like
by like trying to go to war and
threatening these wikipedia mods and
stuff i mean these people have all the
time in the world to do well i mean the
thing is the wikipedia mods take their
jobs very seriously
like this is i do feel like an important
job and these people take it seriously i
know like when i was in college we used
to joke like oh you're really using
wikipedia as a source i feel like it's
actually like a really reliable
trustable source they have they have a
high bar for citing sources
and there's people that really actively
um make sure that the stuff there is
sometimes sometimes i think it's it
depends on the page obviously if it's
really neat what what i think it's good
for is a starting point because like you
said it has good citation well you have
to actually you have to actually go look
at the citations if you like you if you
really because oftentimes
you're only getting part of the picture
yeah you just but it's a great place if
you read something interesting like for
example
what is their citation on that let's see
wonder yeah so
here it says
um
spar
where's the photo
there's three there's three so here it
says
allege that kavanaugh was essentially
running a ponzi scheme
so what's the citation for that
so you haven't even read this right
before i yes yes oh that's the variety
ones it's the variety one
so that one is titled rank have an
accused by ex part of a new ponzi scheme
right
and then the other side is ryan
cavanaugh former business partner
resolve legal drama over okay so right
from the rap which is another industry
publication dueling lawsuits filed
over a stock exchange for a hollywood
movies the hollywood reporter yeah
so you can research that
anyway
pretty awesome
like i said this over the break i'm
going to be working on
sorry i'm chewing gummers i
like to freshen up a little bit there
i'll be working on my uh
ryan cavanaugh magnus opus for the main
channel
beautiful and just need a little time to
commit to it
and there's keemstar stuff of i mean
it's pretty entertaining the keemstar
stuff
but again we've been going for a while
we've been going over three hours now
[Music]
you want to read some donations dan
before we log out sure somebody donated
100 bucks and said for the wiki so thank
you jessica thank you for supporting the
cause you know
take my call i mean alexander hicksten
donated 1090 uh nok
which
is that uh
norway norway
yeah
alexander you said the memes expand
consciousness the memes are vital to
space travel muad means
the meme spice
the meme spice must flow shout out shout
out alexander
yes yeah
uh i'm gonna come
to every episode of the h3 podcast thank
you eric
thank you
well
we'll bait and switch there
let's see what else ethan are you still
watching one piece says somebody from
japan actually i'm on i'm like episode
100 now i'm on the ark
where they're um
they're trying to save that kingdom from
uh
crocodile
and i'm actually i think towards the end
of it but yeah loving it love the show
it's great show
okay really good
uh
let's see
uh somebody said guys have heard of the
diaper thing my roommate's sister dated
guys who admitted to her
a year into their relationship that he
wore diapers it was a long distance
relationship she broke up with him over
it yeah
well you know at least he
told her
ahead of time i'm like or call her
well that is her right
uh question for olivia
olivia do you like simply nail logical
i've watched some of her videos i like
them i'm not
i don't like watch her religiously but
it says if yes have you tried hollow
taco nail polish i have not i am so bad
at painting my own nails it's such a
good nail polish i will check it out
thank you so much it's such
a good nail polish i'm gonna sneak thank
you
i'm gonna come
um
can you guys talk about hassan insulting
people for the color of their skin it
was a big story last weekend do you
agree with that um we'll talk about it
with his son i'm not gonna talk about it
yeah of course i i know about it
that's a very uh interesting way that
you chose to phrase that tangible goods
yeah
i mean that's a little loaded the way
yes
it's not like
we'll talk about with the song okay
uh content chord the little brant fam
they're terrible
interesting you mean the winners of
family of the year by the stream i
refuse to believe that that would be our
third family channel content court if we
were to do that but
both of the ace family and families
look at this thumbnail i'm just
scrolling
that's patrick star oh i thought oh my
god i thought it was demi lovato no
patrick stop i thought the left side was
demi lovato
i'm sorry i'm sorry
i genuinely thought i was like why did
they mix demi lovato with the guy with
the guy's face
and then i had a hard time doesn't look
like her
yes it does
them
i mean maybe it's what i thought yeah i
mean it's what i thought very pretty
makeup
hang on
oh my lord
no let's not double down on this one
maybe you want me to say i see i mean i
see
that's it yeah uh being loved me and
love were just talking about it actually
we're on the side really quick
yeah
delete me from this it looks like some
of the chat agrees too so
i legit thought it was
was
was them
and i'm not even making a joke like
yeah okay i'm sorry about it no i do see
it actually i mean similar facial
structure
um
new website
does demi lovato look like um
[Music]
yeah
jesse nelson says true crime h3 please
it does seem like some people a decent
amount of people are into that idea
yeah awesome uh i hate jay shetty he
repeats the same things over and over
it's so dull
okay well at least you know who he is
yeah that's more than 90 of our audience
dude that is literally the same person
i mean it's not literally the same
person but
i'm just i'm just saying just saying
all right wendy hang on hang on again
just saying
oh god this is hard what the hell is
happening
i'd see what you're drunk
oh no
oh why does it line up so well
i'm kind of impressed how quick you line
that up
well let's see
it's really hard for you to rest play
but somehow
you're able
well the other side is obviously without
makeup so it looks a little off
that's pretty good
[Music]
i refuse to believe that nobody's ever
told them they look like each other
a lot of people in the chat were
agreeing so i think you're on to
something
they're both very pretty yeah they both
are look great they're both fabulous
just saying
you're just saying
tara donated 25 bucks said love you guys
shout out to your families i also miss
out on the live streams also well you're
here
you're here on this one
also today is our seven year wedding
anniversary happy anniversary
we love happy couples love love love
um also you and elia need to go back on
your mom's house with the maine mommies
yeah they're in tech yeah yeah i'd love
to
you know uh did you see the island boys
stormed off of logan paul's podcast it
was on impulsive tick tock i did not
i did not i do i don't know what were
they fighting about
i actually don't even know what they
were fighting about it was just a guy on
the couch
was like i don't have a problem with you
and they were like why do you have a
problem with me and he was like i didn't
and then
they just i saw it yeah i just i didn't
understand what they were fighting about
or anything yeah i didn't see the like
origin of the fight i think the island
boys are story arc is coming to a close
yeah
i think it's kind of running going on
impulsive was kind of the last stop uh
yeah
on their on their way out
damn they did a show where they were
getting booed on stage and [ __ ]
you see that dan yes i'm just an island
boy everyone's like boo
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
uh talk about the singer from brass
against who gave a golden shower to an
unsuspecting fan on stage
so crazy long time listener first time
messaging yes thank you ryan uh saw that
too that was
pretty odd
it wasn't unsuspecting though but
they're not that like volunteered to to
do it i believe yeah but still i mean
they're a brass band it's not that rock
i know they're like do brass band rage
against the machine yeah they do like
total covers and you're still playing a
brass band yeah i weirdly i was familiar
with them i watched some of their
youtube videos of their covers of like
tool songs they're opening up for tool
on their next tour
are they still or did this controversy
that said they're still opening up okay
well it's good yeah i mean it's pretty
rock and roll like i mean i'm not
they're doing rock and roll you can you
can pee on stage you can pee on
someone's face it's all
it's all good gg allen [ __ ]
right
uh
uh
there's there's so many more i'm trying
to find like
okay fifty dollars canadian canadian
dollars
that's even more right i think it's less
oh [ __ ]
ethan have you heard of the kellogg
strike if you haven't no
can you give a brief tlldr of it by
reading senator tim kaine's
tweet uh i have a little bit it's pretty
wild they um
they tried to
they've been like a wage dispute for a
while and they tried to fire all the
workers uh last week and bring in new
people and apparently it was just like a
total [ __ ] disaster and then
i guess like
people on reddit organized spamming
their job application portal with just
like joke applications so they can't
even get anything
basically that's interesting it's very
it is pretty interesting maybe we'll
talk about it on leftovers this weekend
yeah that's a pretty interesting story
we should talk about it on leftovers
yeah um
good spot
i'm at the fedex facility near where the
tornadoes in the midwest are and we have
a town's worth of packages to go through
thank you so much for everyone in the
crew bless up yeah stay safe that story
was insane i think the definition of
like 80 or something though so insane
how much did you say dan i think it's
like close to 80. i heard that they were
guessing it was over a hundred
yeah of like the confirmed four dead
seven four dead
dude i saw a really good take they're
like oh it was such an unexpected
natural disaster but the majority of
people died who were working at like 3
a.m and olfactory
knew the weather was coming
i mean it was just uh more casualties of
late stage capitalism it sounded like
a little bit
a little bit
um okay there's more coming in but um
here i'll read this one last
stephanie
you're the winner christine and ben of
simply nail holo taco are friends of the
show she even did a nail design of teddy
fresh oh
uh last paid comment of them
i don't know what that last sentence
means but that's cool i'll have to check
that out love that shout out i mean i
think i've spoken to her on instagram or
something obviously i don't follow like
nails and makeup and stuff but
i know over
trying to line up the lips it's a little
more working on that it's a little more
difficult on this side shouldn't you do
it half like
half of the face that's harder okay cam
can you do cam do me a favor um
edit the the makeup tap
of his face
and line it up with the half of their
face
wait yeah hold on let me let me give me
pull up pull up the other uh
the other person let's get to the bottom
of this
pull up
pull up the other thumbnail ethan
i need to screen cap it the one that
the half and half face
yeah all right hold on
thank you all right
you're on a timer
let's go let's get a little uh two face
action going on those two you see that
cam
well anyway as we we're basically
wrapping up that'll be our final thing
but
look at this sweater so nice with the
collar built in and the bears
i love this top oh i just
notice the whole time that you one of
those bears were killed
okay so
thank you guys for watching
mondays are always fun
you know h3tv
that's right
all right that's right thank you guys
for being here
we'll be back we're having a usual
schedule this week
back on it's been a while since we've
had thursday
thursday wednesday for members are we
doing anything this week going off the
rails do anything planner i think it's a
normal off the rails which we haven't
done in a couple weeks so
yeah we have some great episodes planned
when we come back including nick acado
right yep
oliver tree all the trees in the works
fun fun stuff oh sound bite tier list
we're gonna do
is that um next week ian or this week
might be this week it might be this uh
we'll do our annual second annual
soundbite tier list that was a lot of
fun we have a lot of updates oh my god
this is like straight up two-face it's
cursed yeah super curse
holy [ __ ]
but like
come on
send this to ever send this to everybody
i don't even know who the guy is but
a makeup guru yeah he's a guru
just like swami
so true
legend
swami is an actual guru yeah he doesn't
appropriate the word to talk about
something else
he's helped me discover things about
myself
like that my name should be eddie
it's eddie sounds like a b
it does a b a d a d a b
sometimes even after being corrected i
guess it still sounds like eddie swami
told me he wants to jam with me
yeah he told me that this morning as
well
i love that
he wants to do a music collab with me oh
[ __ ] i said okay
let's do it whatever you want swamps
all right i gotta go all right thank you
for watching everyone we'll see you on
thursday and uh friday and sunday you
know the drill it's the last full week
of the 8th podcast before our break
anyway guys have a great week see you on
thursday or wednesday if you remember
[Music]
[Music]
you